This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is one of the podcasts that we
recorded.
Why we recording the Scifi show,
Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
A lot of people have listened to those shows and they've said,
hey man,
I love your show,
but the fucking fig podcasts are killing me.
They actually weren't fake.
The way we did the show was we did everything that we do during a normal podcast
and [inaudible] and then we just talked about the subject at hand.
And of course a lot of times the subjects went on crazy tangents like,
like any other podcasts that we do.
Uh,
but they were all recorded just like a regular podcast.
And then we had the Scifi people or um,
the,
uh,
people at Arthur Smith,
the production company that made the show,
um,
edit down portions of it and insert those.
So there were some things that we said that,
you know,
sort of busy work,
like w things that we had to say,
like,
Dunkin,
I'm going to send you to go check,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
There was just stuff that we had to do for the show.
But other than that,
the majority of it was just regular podcast talk and I promise you guys that I
would release it and uh,
thanks to the generosity of Scifi,
they have allowed us to do so.
So we're going to put all these podcasts out there.
How many of them are there,
Jamie?
10 or 11.
So there's like 10 or 11.
They range between,
uh,
two hours plus for this first one to short ones are probably like an hour
something,
something along those lines.
But uh,
this is the first one and this one is brought to you by ting.
So if you go to rogan.ting.com you can find out what Ting is all about.
Ting is an excellent cell phone service company that uses the sprint backbone.
And Sprint of course is one of the biggest cell phone providers in the world and
in the country.
So you don't have to worry about getting a crappy cell phone signal along with
saving money.
But with Tim does is they have it set up so that you only pay for what you use.
If you have,
like if you go to the,
if you go to rogan.ting.com there's a sign that says 98% of people would save
money with Ting.
That's because we do mobile differently and they really do.
It's not bullshit if you don't use,
if you like,
say if you have one plan and then you use less than that plan,
they will credit you the difference on your next bill.
Who the fuck does that?
Nobody,
nobody does that.
Tim does that.
$21 is the average monthly bill per device per device for 10 customers.
That's fucking nuts.
$440 is the average annual savings per device for a business with 11 to 20
employees.
I mean Ting is bad ass and they have great phones.
They have the HTC one,
which is uh,
a one my friend at Google gave me that I've been playing with.
I love it.
It's a great phone.
It's really cool.
The,
uh,
the devices they have are all top of the line and droid phones.
They have,
you know,
these all these beautiful android devices like the Samsung Galaxy s four s three
fucking HTC one.
They have the HTC one black.
If you're looking sexy and you need your phone to be black and mysterious,
or the ht one red,
if you're flamboyant,
you're just a wild child.
You can't be held back.
They have the Motorola Moto X,
which is a bad ass device.
Um,
I've,
uh,
I've been really interested in that phone.
That's,
there's all these new phones that they're coming out with these android phones
and they're coming out with them in a much more rapid pace.
Then,
um,
a lot of the other providers like apple,
you know,
apple with their five s you silly pitches.
Can you give me a big screen?
You're fucks.
Come on.
Seriously.
Gimme a big scream.
Um,
I know ting was going to have,
they had the iPhone for a while.
They have it anymore.
Hmm.
Smartphones,
let's say two,
two,
two.
They have the HTC,
uh,
eight x t,
which is a windows phone.
Um,
I have not fucked with windows phones,
but I have a friend who loves them.
I don't trust him.
I think he might be one of those dudes,
some of those people,
and not saying there's anything wrong with windows phones.
I'm sure there are bad ass,
but there are people that I think you know them,
we all know them,
that when they have something they want other people to get it.
Like I had a friend and he had this old piece of shit,
weird fucking stuff.
This is a long time ago.
It was like,
um,
I think it was a Sony cell phone and it had a,
it had like a,
like,
like a little pencil that came with it,
a stylist and he would write on it and they would recognize his handwriting and
it's a fucked,
I mean they're barely recognized it and it was,
it had all these like really wonky,
shitty apps.
It would crash on you,
but he was just ranting and raving about how great it was.
Then I saw the motherfucker three months later with an iPhone.
I was like,
bitch,
what are you trying to do?
You fucking tried to sell me on the same shit that you're on.
It's like people that are on sprint,
they want you to be on sprint.
People are on at and t like you needed,
you didn't need,
but people who are on ting or on tin because they're saving money son,
they're saving themselves some shackles and they're trying to set up a cell
phone company that does it ethically,
that gives you great service,
doesn't give you any contracts.
You can cancel anytime you want and as I said,
if you don't use all of your minutes,
they will knock you down to the lower rate and they will credit you.
Ting is a mobile service that makes sense.
It's a no bullshit mobile service company.
They use sprint credit,
new services,
no add on charges,
no mysterious line items for your bill.
You ever get a bill and you're like,
what is this fucking service fee,
Kim?
All that creepy shit the big companies do to try to extract money from you.
Tank's not about that son.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save $25 off of any device or service.
So go there,
check it out and I guarantee you you will enjoy it.
It is an excellent company.
We uh,
we give them a full recommendation.
Brian has been using Tang for for quite a while and one of the things he notices
when he went out of town,
he went to Canada.
You use tango internationally.
He saved a shit load of money compared to our friends who used a other less
scrupulous services.
So go there,
check out all the bad ass cell phones.
Like I said,
I'd like the galaxy s four.
You can get the s four purple if you're a big prince fan or you can get the
galaxy note to titanium.
Chased us to tow crazy.
These phones go there.
rogan.ting.com and now I'm with a big thank you to the syfy network.
Uh,
I really enjoyed working with them and I really appreciate the fact that they're
allowing us to release these podcasts.
They were very cool.
It was very cool.
They want to put the show on and a to we slammed it together so quickly.
Uh,
short notice though.
So,
uh,
thank you to them and a thank you to everybody over at Arthur Smith as well.
Thanks to frank and Michael and,
and Todd and all the cool folks that we worked with.
So,
uh,
with that,
with without any further ado,
this is a one of many of the Psi Phi podcasts for the Joe Rogan experience.
They kiss you on the Joe Rogan
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
So the Joe Rogan experience podcast,
it's not real.
We're pretending that it's real.
Only 10 carefully,
properly.
Joe,
you should go to Canada.
I heard there's a hum there.
Get the fuck out
and cut.
That was perfect.
Okay.
So there's a lot of people that believe that the government not only is capable
of manipulating the weather,
but does manipulate the weather and we know that they've done certain things
like we know that people can make it rain and not just at a strip club,
but people can make it rain by spraying certain chemicals into the clouds or
seeding clouds,
child seating.
They have actually done that in the United Arab Emirates.
They've made it rain 50 times last year,
so they do it basically once a week.
But this is I,
this is,
I've heard it's dangerous.
Like the chemicals that come with a rain are poisonous.
Oh,
right,
true.
I don't know.
Well,
it's weird.
Chemicals sprayed out of an Arabs jet,
not,
I don't think weird.
Let's
say cloud cities that you never in human history has anyone flown over a desert
and sprayed chemicals into a cloud?
It's
okay.
Let's find out.
Is Cloud seeding harmful?
That's what a lot of people want to know.
Duncan Trussell.
And when studying the efficacy and consequences of cloud seeding experience,
the experimenters tend to be biased towards saying cloud seeding with silver
iodide enhances precipitation without negative consequences.
However,
much of the literature substantiates that,
not only does cloud seeding fail to achieve the desired effect,
it also yields harmful consequence.
Also look up that guy eight silver iodide.
If you ever got a turn purple.
Yeah,
that blueberry man.
Yeah.
What happened there?
You eat silver.
These people eat silver out of some.
They think it increases their longevity or their virility and it makes them turn
smurf blue forever.
Hmm.
So this is one take on it and there's other takes on it.
That's the problem with the Internet,
right?
Is that if you really wanted to,
you could find a bunch of people that agree with you and just hanging those
circles.
It's the beauty of the Internet and it's the problem with the Internet.
The fact that there's so much information out there,
but if you choose to,
you can filter it down and get it to a point where you're not really listening
to anybody other than people that support your point of
I don't need the Internet to help me figure out if I want to stand under a cloud
pouring silver iodide,
crystallized rain and into my yard.
Like if someone gave you a choice,
do you want to stand in a rain shower of PuroClean Hawaiian water or would you
like to stand in a silver iodide rain,
shower and joy,
those relaxing silver particles spilling into your skin?
Well,
here's the other side of it.
They can also prevent it from raining.
Um,
the,
we know China did that during the Olympics and uh,
other than preventing rain for the Olympics,
it says here in this article on space-explores.com,
whatever it says here in this article that other than preventing rain for the
Olympics,
China is spending 60 to that other than preventing rain for the Olympics,
China is spending 60 to $90 million a year on cloud seeding to provide enough
water for its enormous population to clear away smog from heavily polluted
areas.
So that's their way of dealing with smart.
Hey,
do you think we should like put mufflers on our cars now let's just make it
rain.
Just wash it.
Oh yeah.
Just push it down into the corner.
Dyed water.
Good.
It's really good for pollution.
China is going to give China is going to birth the Godzilla there.
Fucking around with that.
We can't say that it would beep it out.
No,
I yeah,
I yourself God damn it.
I think that's a powerful weapon though,
man.
It really is.
If you want it to attack a country and you could make rain stop.
Yeah.
Then you would have full power over that country.
If you could control their weather,
you've definitely would win.
And then the question is,
if you could do that,
how do you know you can do that?
Well,
you'd have to try it.
And how did you try it?
Did you try it just during the Olympics or did you know about it beforehand?
Have you been using it on countries?
Have you been aiming it in places?
Like how do you do it?
You have to,
is it very specific or you know,
can it be,
can
you misfire and it is,
people can get cotton drive by accidental cloud seatings where it would rain in
a place where you didn't want it to rain.
That doesn't even make sense.
Dry by accidental cloud seeding.
It ricocheted stray clouds.
You get Ma'am got hit by a stray cloud.
That would be a great dramatic get hit by,
he made it rain on my family.
I'm not even a crip
now besides the chem trail issue,
which,
uh,
we've,
I've met with a bunch of people so far on this camp trail issue and there's
certainly some,
there's certainly some possibilities that the government at one point in time
has sprayed something from a plane for sure.
Sure.
But the idea of this constant spraying and this in the skies,
the idea,
this constant spraying and this guys seems to be much more ignorance than
anything else.
I agree.
Yeah.
And not just ignorance,
but like on purpose,
like being willfully ignorant,
like not looking at any of the things that refute the things you're saying.
It's scientifically people with no agenda.
Instead looking only at the things that support it.
Well,
you know,
confirmation bias,
it's like pure and simple.
And there's people that make entire documentaries.
This guy that I met with,
this guy,
um,
Michael Murphy,
he's got these two documentaries.
What in the world are they spraying and why in the world are they spraying?
And he refuses to look at anything that points to the fact that what he's
measuring when he's measuring like aluminum,
he's saying Lloyd's,
look,
we found aluminum and this water,
what he's measuring his dirt and dirt is rich in aluminum.
I mean it's,
it's a real simple stuff,
right?
So that in saying that this is a part of some nefarious plan and some secret
thing that he's uncovered is being ridiculous person.
Also,
I like to think about the specifics of the person flying the plane that's
apparently dropping the poison onto there.
It's like who are these mysterious pilots?
Did they have breakfast with their family?
Do they sit down and chat about how,
yeah,
going to spray aluminum dichloride over New York,
honey.
And the other thing is it's so nonspecific.
I mean everyone down there is the enemy or everyone down there has to be
experimented with including billionaires,
bankers,
politicians,
they're all getting sprayed on everybody.
Really.
What kind of asshole would do that?
That's the real question.
And not only that,
what a shit result like it barely does anything.
I mean stop and think about all this spring.
Imagine if you had something where you can spray this guy completely cover the
sky in this spray,
this chemical spray and what does it do to the people down there?
It makes prince freak out.
It makes prince freak out almost worth.
We got to pull that up.
Pull up prince talks about chem trails.
This is a very important,
actually put,
it's a youtube video.
Prince talks to Dick Gregory about chem trails areas.
It's hilariously awesome and it,
it,
it highlights a lot of people's ignorance about this issue.
Like they haven't even looked into what creates these clouds.
And this was a paper that was published by the,
uh,
the United military in the 1940s,
and they didn't call them con trails back then.
They called them persistent condensation trails and they were trying to
determine that these clouds they were making with propellers.
By the way,
if these clouds,
whether or not they were dangerous and the same conditions were always
discussed,
it's always like super hazy.
And it's at a point just before clouds are created,
like a point in the,
the condensation of the atmosphere where it's almost cloudy.
It's just kind of hazy.
And when they cut through with a plane,
it creates artificial clouds.
And when people saying they're spraying clouds,
no,
they're actually making clouds by driving through it with a plane.
I mean,
it's really simple stuff.
Yeah.
I,
I've never really bought into that stuff,
but I have had somebody explained to me how they're putting poison into the air.
Someone explained that to me while smoking a cigarette while taking big puffs on
a,
say they're poisoning as a deadly chemicals in the air,
man.
They just want to control the population.
Yeah.
I've seen people talk about saving the environment,
whether it drove a Prius and throw a cigarette out the window.
It's ridiculous.
But you know,
I don't,
honestly,
I don't understand what makes those things up in the air.
I think they're pretty like criss crossing pattern clouds.
They're nice to look at it on a picnic,
but I don't think they're poison.
And why is it that they keep appearing near airports?
That's crazy.
Why would they spray near the airport?
Because that way they could do it rather than under our noses.
Man.
The biggest lie is the lie that you don't even have to tell.
Everybody tells us for you ps,
the government could probably release free packs of cigarettes that say on them,
these make you depressed and people would just bought willingly buy them.
You don't have to secretly dump chemicals on Americans.
We're gulping them down every day.
We love chemicals sit in front of a seven 11 and watch those pigs come flapping
out of there with their big gulps and their pasty glistening sugar,
sugar lips and fried hot dogs.
No,
you don't have to poison a merit.
The idea that you have to actively and secretly poisoned Americans is insane.
It's ridiculous.
So I think we both agree on that.
They obviously know how to manipulate weather and they obviously have
manipulated whether before and by they meaning everyone but us.
Okay.
I don't think you'd done any manipulation and so we'll just include the whole
rest of the population.
Someone out there has figured out how to make it stop raining and they've also
figured out how to make it rain.
Yes.
The question is how often does it does go on and is this a part of our everyday
life that we have to concern ourselves with and does it spray down harmful
chemicals?
Is the other,
those clouds of the reason why people are finding aluminum,
the soil,
well it turns out no aluminum is one of the most common elements on earth.
And it's,
you can find commensurate levels that they've been finding in these tests that
they've done that prove chem trails a real,
you find those everywhere all over the country.
The reason being,
because fucking aluminum is everywhere.
Yes.
Aluminum's everywhere.
So that's something we know we don't have to worry about.
So we've got that put
us put aside.
So a plane's create clouds automatically proven be aluminum exists in the
atmosphere all the time.
Proves right.
Doesn't mean that they haven't sprayed things from the sky.
It doesn't mean that they're not capable of altering the weather.
We know they are.
Right?
Sure.
But then also isn't there always toxins coming off of airplanes no matter why
jet fuel that's on fire.
Yeah,
and it's sprays.
And by the way,
that's the one of the biggest factors in global warming is jets,
right?
Giant tubes filled with flammable dead dinosaurs that you're flying over the sky
once that spraying,
that's the real spraying.
The real spraying is burning jet fuel above your face.
Stupid.
Exactly.
That's the poison.
They really are spraying us every time you fly to The Bahamas,
you're chipping in.
That's what I heard.
I heard every time you fly your fat kids to Disneyland,
you're incinerating like 19 acres of rain forest.
How do they get to that much?
But I feel I exactly eating a lot of different ways when I said that.
Now the other aspect
of manipulating,
whether that's fascinating is harp and I think Harb stands for high altitude
active auroral research.
Let's find that one.
I don't know.
H.
A r.
P just so we know it stands for,
oh,
I spelled it totally wrong.
I spelled it h.
H a r,
which is the Hebrew home for the aged in Riverdale.
Okay.
Not the same thing.
Don't go there and yell at those people for controlling the weather.
Jewish elderly people are making it rain and
they don't even know what you're talking about and they will hit you.
Okay.
High frequency active auroral research program.
Yeah,
and this is a fascinating thing because what this is the official use of harp is
that they,
they send these radio waves up into the ionosphere and they can manipulate it,
and by manipulating it,
it can aid in communication.
They could shut down communication and they could possibly make it so that they
can send radio signals and receive radio signals from very far away.
What's the ionosphere?
The ionosphere?
That's a good question.
We should get the official
explanation without me going into my pseudoscience.
Okay.
Here we go.
It's the layer of the earth's atmosphere that contains a high concentration of
ions and free electrons and is able to reflect radio.
So that's the ionosphere.
So it makes sense that they would have these,
this gigantic radio array antenna ray,
and that they're sending these charged particles up into the ionosphere and that
what they're trying to do is manipulate it so that they can use their radios
more effectively.
However,
the conspiracy theory and the conspiracy harp has been blamed for a variety of
different events,
um,
including numerous natural disasters,
tsunamis.
Some people think they can cause earthquake and some people attribute it to
something called sky quakes.
Have you ever heard of sky quake?
Now listen to this.
Okay,
we're gonna play this for you.
This is an audio of a sky quake.
And let's play.
Let's play the one from Allen,
Texas.
There's a bunch of people that are standing outside and they hear this,
and the freaky thing they say is that when they hear these things that you can't
pinpoint where they're coming from.
They're just coming from the sky.
And in order to have something that's that loud that doesn't dissipate with
distance,
you're dealing with some incredible amount of energy.
And the big F is as if this isn't a hoax,
right?
You could get some Dick heads in college and think it's cute to just stand
around and go,
what's that sound?
What is that?
And then they go on their computer and add in some sound effects.
Yeah,
just slow down a trumpet and put it your picnic video.
And suddenly you've got 15 billion hits on Youtube.
Yeah,
exactly.
And again,
it's one of those things,
it's like what exactly are we listening to this?
It sounds cool.
Oh,
I didn't know this is called sky quakes,
but I have heard of this.
And what I really like is the Judeo Christian explanation for what this is.
Because in the book of revelations,
they talk about how the horsemen of the apocalypse blow these trumpets.
And that's how you know it's the end of days.
So this is really feeding into the apocalyptic Christian theory that we're at
the end of the world.
And these are the sounds that you hear before the great plagues come rolling
through the land.
That's what a lot of Christians think that.
Did you ever see Kevin Smith's movie?
Red State?
Ah,
yes,
I did.
Amazing movie.
And remember the end when they played the trumpet and that's what got the crazy
evangelism and make it to the end.
I was drunk,
I fell asleep.
It's worth a second look.
Um,
now we also have some recordings of what harp actually sounds like in operation.
And this is equally freaky.
It's not a good sound that you never want to hear that.
You never want to be out on your porch with your dog throwing a stick and you're
like,
what is what?
So what is hard?
What do they have?
Like demons yelling in a microphones.
I think it's the garbage disposal of the universe.
That's what it sounds like.
It sounds like a garbage disposal and space.
No,
this sounds like interstellar locust
descending on the,
when you really stop and think about the fact that there's something on earth
that shoots energy up into the sky and makes that noise.
Yeah.
And then above us,
what?
What is it shooting into the ionosphere where there's like thousands of
satellites and space junk flying in it just,
no thanks.
No thanks to creeps were a creepy species.
Can you imagine if if chimpanzees were blasting the honest fear with devil
screeches,
we kill them,
wipe them out with him.
Two days there'd be no more chimps.
We found chimp with a bow and Arrow would shoot it right in the head.
You'd have to,
you'd have to.
Yeah.
So this,
what's interesting about this is it like Robin Hood and make a ton of money.
We had this guy on the show that I interviewed,
his name is woody Norris.
He's this genius inventor,
a true bonafide genius.
He's responsible for over 80 patents.
He is a an audio expert and he listened to the sounds and review the amount of
power this thing puts out and he believes that this,
this array of antennas absolutely could be responsible for those sounds.
And he thinks that it could be responsible for manipulating whether it can,
that you could have a lot of what you would call off label uses and that maybe
it was an issue initially created to heat up the ionosphere so that they could
send radio signals.
But along the way they might've figured out,
Holy Shit,
we can make trumpets blow in the sky over Iran.
You know?
I mean,
do you know how freaky it would be is like,
you know,
you get an email from the president,
good luck,
fuck face,
we're going to war.
And then he had a raw,
you'd know it's common and you hear trumpets in the sky.
Just that alone is like,
listen,
we've been thinking,
we've been very hasty.
The nuclear who needs nuclear power?
My friend,
he stopped the trumpet.
Japan has problems with it.
So we don't want that in this world.
No.
You know what,
man,
I think that for whatever reason,
it's part of the government's job to every day come up with new ways to kill
people.
And someone looks at tornadoes when tornadoes hit and thinks,
wow,
that would make a great weapon.
If I could figure out a way to do that,
I'd have the ultimate weapon.
Because the problem with nuclear bombs,
aside,
aside from the fact that they like kill hundreds of thousands of innocent
people,
is they irradiate where they hit.
So you end up not being able to move into that area as a good conquer would want
to.
Cause everything's full radiation.
Everything's like Chernobyl.
So you know,
and with bioweapons the same thing.
Well that was the hydrogen bombs.
That was the idea behind the hydrogen bomb was that you could kill everyone
there.
But leave the structures.
Yeah.
Can you imagine that pitch meeting where somebody,
he's like pitching that I've innovated something great.
We can leave the structures and kill all the people.
Great Gym.
But with this,
with this idea,
it's sort of like a in between thing,
which is that not only could you send in tornadoes or earthquakes to wipe out
populations,
but also you could do it anonymously.
No one would even know who is doing the attack.
You would just think you were having some bad geological luck for a few years
until everything's flattened.
And then the UN comes in.
It's like,
well look,
we're going to help you rebuild.
And then the next thing you know you've been infiltrated by the empire taken
over and you don't even know it.
It's the ultimate weapon.
So it makes a lot of sense that a,
that a government or an empire would want to investigate this stuff.
Absolutely.
And if this was a possibility,
they would certainly explore it and look into it.
The real question is have they ever used it?
And that's the beauty of this thing being sort of an anonymous thing.
If you really can create a storm,
how would you know that someone created a storm or whether or not it's just a
storm.
You,
you,
you send a nuclear bomb,
there's an obvious footprint.
There's sure you know where it came from.
We know a human created it.
They,
they connect the dots.
They find out you can't,
like,
it's not like throwing a snowball in a car and running behind a bush.
When you,
when you throw a nuclear bomb,
you get caught.
Every,
everybody knows you're an asshole.
You don't need Colombo to solve that one.
[inaudible] question is,
do you think that they've done it already?
That's the real question though.
The question is not,
can they manipulate the weather?
It's been proven.
Can they manipulate with harp?
We don't know.
But if they could have they already,
yeah,
just I,
I think so.
I,
yeah,
sure.
If they could,
if they could,
they've definitely done it.
Do you think that they could do it with harp?
I think harp is creepy.
I had never heard those sounds before,
but I've seen that array of,
um,
uh,
antenna and there's spooky looking.
And also I heard that security at harp is like area 51 level security and I've
also heard that they don't,
they're very,
very secretive about what's going on over there.
So I wouldn't surprise me if I had something to do with controlling the weather.
That doesn't surprise me at all.
I don't know.
I would hate to break up with someone who worked at Harv is reigns over your
house for a year straight.
It's just always cloudy in your neighborhood.
Well,
let's listen to what some experts say because a Stanford University professor
[inaudible] said to popular science that weather control conspiracy theories
were completely uninformed and he explained that there's absolutely nothing that
we can do to disturb the earth's weather systems.
And even though the power that harp radiates is very large,
it's minuscule compared with the power of a lightning flash and there are 50 to
a hundred lightning flashes every second harps.
Intensity is very small,
but he could just be a shill.
Who knows?
He could be working for the man.
Who knows,
man,
I to Stanford teaching all those liberals.
He's a lot more credible than some hipster.
And a fedora with a beard yapping about tornadoes.
Are you a hipster?
Officially?
I don't know,
but I mean I could be called wine and I get judged like that.
But again,
who knows?
Man,
I,
I just think that the government has explored in governments of the world if
explored how to kill people and almost every possible way from coming up with
weaponized smallpox to using nuclear bombs.
So why wouldn't they explore it?
Something like the weather,
it makes a hundred percent absolute sense and
you no one else for sure.
This Omran in non is not hanging out at harp.
Okay.
He's not going up there.
He's not talking to those scientists.
He's not absolutely clearly informed as to what they're capable of.
Right.
And there's one thing that really smart people love to do and that they love to
dismiss things that they believe are silly or things that don't agree with what
they've stated.
Yup.
And so a lot of these guys that are saying this like computer scientist David
Nadick who characterize harp as a magnet for conspiracy theorists and says that
harp attracts their attention because it's purpose seems deeply mysterious to
the scientifically uninformed.
He says that.
But when you talked to geniuses and experts in sound and in the power output and
they talk about the,
uh,
the capabilities of a system like harp there,
like you're talking about something that's being run by Darpa,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
let's pull up.
What does Darpa stand for?
Cause I think it's something evil.
It's definitely something evil.
The defense.
Advanced research projects.
Agency defense.
I mean maybe that means defense as in they need to charge up the ionosphere
descend radio signals or maybe it means that a sound robot in the sky is going
to eat your baby.
Absolutely.
And have you seen that other crap Darpa spits out of their health,
those robots that you can kick and they don't fall over deadly galloping dogs.
Weird springing attack.
Frogs death drones.
Like of course they're trying them and have their own Twitter though.
Oh,
follow them right now.
Bam.
The official Twitter account for the defense.
Advanced Research Projects Agency follow.
They have 50,000 followers.
Sure.
Wow.
How many of you have 75 you have more than Darpa.
That sad suck at Darpa.
Yeah,
that's what I say.
Fuck off Darpa.
No,
I love you darling.
Would like to come work there.
I'm going to Alaska and a couple of weeks to do stand up.
I want to visit.
Do you think they'll still let me in?
Yes.
No,
no.
It's like the one of the most secure places on the planet.
They let you in.
That's one of the saddest things when you run into like any of these people that
you've villainized and you're,
I was like,
yeah,
come on in.
Check it is thing out.
We've got,
yeah,
we're just trying to make radio waves work better.
Yeah.
And then you leave and they laugh.
They turn back into reptiles that fuck it.
I got his phone.
Let's follow home kills dog.
Dog died of a heart attack.
Well,
you know,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
you know.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
I didn't.
So there's some things I've learned today.
I didn't know that harp was run by Darpa.
I had no idea that there was any connection there because I said that.
But let's make sure that that's correct.
Harp run by Darpa.
I think it's true.
High Frequency Dee Dee,
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee,
you n the defense.
Yep.
Okay.
So that's pretty weird because Darpa is a notorious creator of things that are
without question going to destroy our civilization.
They just gleefully whip up death machines,
um,
without any concern for what's going to happen 50 years from now,
sort of.
Or maybe they just make good defensive stuff to keep the defense
defense.
Offensive Defensive Department of Defense.
Yes.
It about Dunkin and keeping us safe.
It's about the defense.
You know what neat about offense being offensive?
You know what made me feel really safe?
Uh,
a galloping robotic dog,
they can chase me over may or may not have cannons on it.
Galloping dog that's half made of c four that makes its way into your building
and then makes a volcano explodes.
I felt so scared.
I used to be so nervous.
I'd walk around with fear inside of me until those packs of wild galloping
Cyborg dogs made solar powered dogs and by the way,
they could be solar powered.
No,
ain't just to run all day.
It never rains here and they can be autonomous to,
or they're just controlled by 18 year olds and trailers outside of Vegas with
with Xbox controllers all messed up on government speed.
Yeah,
look at a speed that they give those those drone operator.
He makes sure they're hopped up on the good stuff.
If you want speed,
talk to a drone operator,
they've got the good stuff.
They don't need big gulps.
I didn't even drink water.
They just have a pace to their chew on.
They don't,
they don't take in any moisture.
Moisture disrupts the effects of the electrolyte
imbalance that math provides.
Darpa in the Internet because I think Darpa invented the Internet.
I thought Al Gore did
a,
I think Darpa did invent the Internet,
which is going to create a thank you,
right too.
E
involved in the creation of the Internet and history of the Internet.
Formal group with Darpa,
the fruit.
A group within Darpa.
Huh?
Brief history.
Then in 1973
okay.
Yeah.
Well,
here's what's interesting.
[inaudible] Darpa is also linked to the creation of the Internet,
which is fascinating.
In 1973 the US defense advanced research project agency or Darpa,
initiated a research program to investigate techniques and technologies for
interlinking packet networks of various kinds.
The objective was to develop communication protocols,
which would allow network computers to communicate transparently across multiple
linked packet networks.
So it was created by Darpa.
The very thing that will bring down the empire was created by it.
Well,
see,
that's what I,
that's what happens to all mad scientists is their creation turns against that.
So true.
Frankenstein.
Yeah.
It was killed by Frankenstein.
It's an inevitability.
It is,
isn't it?
Yeah.
So this thing that,
so they unleashed the internet.
Who knows what else they've unleashed or they're going to unleash,
but you know what else?
The Internet did inform people about mushrooms maybe that can help them with
Darpa needs mushrooms.
That's what they need.
Imagine the kind of shit that you could create if you had the technology and the
resources of Darpa.
Yeah,
but it was all people on mushrooms.
They're beautiful world.
It'd be amazing.
Think of what burning man would look like if Darpa took it over.
They would kill all the people begging for sandwiches.
That'd be the first thing.
Take him outside of we know how to do it.
Them like they didn't even care.
Even if they're on mushrooms and just still just shoot hippies.
Let's tell you,
just knew you did that.
Come on guys.
Stop crying in.
Know that brother was a loser.
You brother had dirty feet.
Come on,
come on.
We shot him.
What's the big deal?
I got more mushrooms.
Who wants to sing?
Who wants to get in a drum circle?
Drones that shoot poison darts at anything that smells like Patchouli.
Some hot girls.
It's more like a truly a lot.
A lot of hot girls.
Some girls,
they were like little oil.
Just as a gentle like I look very oil.
Mm hmm.
I love that sweet smell up at Julian and I body the sweet smell.
But truly and bumper stickers.
I like the sweet smell of it,
Julie,
cause there's usually like good acid around.
Now here's the other thing.
Here's the other thing that people think a harp is responsible for.
There's a thing in Windsor and it's called the Windsor Hum.
And these poor people that live in this town that's across the river from Zug
Island,
which is near Detroit.
And these poor people that live in Windsor,
they say that their houses rattle their windows rattle and sometimes it's 24
hours a day.
Just whoo,
whoo,
whoo.
That's how they all describe it.
And no one can seem to locate the source of it.
Some people say that it's coming from Zug Island and some people say that even
though you can't hear it near Zug island,
it gets more powerful.
The further away you get.
And they describe it as like a tsunami effect that like a tsunami,
like it starts in one place,
then builds up powers.
It moves along well.
If you talked to anybody knows anything about sound,
they say that's not how sound works,
but they seem to describe it that way.
They just scream seem to describe it as a sound that's coming from a place where
they can't quite pinpoint where it is.
They want to say it's coming towards Zug island.
But some folks say that as you get closer to Zug island,
it actually is less noisy than it is when you're further away from it.
It's a really weird thing and it's not one person complaining about this.
You're talking about an entire town of people.
We talked to several people,
not one of them was like,
what are you talking to?
Does anybody live on Zug Island?
No.
Zug Island
is gross.
We went to visit.
Sounds great with such a beautiful name.
Who would think that it would be gross?
Zug Island stinks.
It smells like pollution.
You could buy a house across the river from Zug island for 500 bucks.
That's how bad it is.
So there,
so what you're saying is there's this low resonant hum.
I'm merging from a place called Zug island
and would Zug island is for,
it's,
it's it cross from Detroit.
It's a part of Detroit and it's for you.
They make steel there and they have these giant piles of raw materials and these
furnaces.
And we talked to a guy named Gregory Fornia who worked there in the 1960s and it
was,
he said it was always disgusting and it was always dangerous and it was always
environmental hazards.
This is really,
really polluted.
The river around there is one of the 10 most polluted places in the United
States,
and yet people are fishing there and pulling fish out left and right where we're
there.
So it really kind of scary stuff.
But he,
he said that what they're doing,
they're a wood they've always been doing there is manufacturing steel and he
believes that that sound is just a part of the process,
the,
the process of creating and making steel.
Sure.
That makes sense.
It does make sense.
What doesn't make sense though is the sound itself,
when you bring the sound to sound experts and you say,
is it possible that this sound was recorded six miles,
five miles?
Is it possible?
This sound was recorded x amount of miles away from a source and was this loud
in a person's house and they say,
no way.
We met a guy in Windsor named Gary Gross and Gary recorded some sounds that he
says are the winds are home.
All right.
And listen to this.
We're going to play it for you.
Huh?
The imagine being in your house.
Okay.
And there's something here like this and he is miles away from Zug island.
I mean,
it sounds like you're outside of nightclub.
It sounds like high powered bass speakers.
Huh?
Inside a building.
Except there's nothing near him.
He's just in his house and everyone in his neighborhood feels it as well.
So you're not talking about something that's like a car that has giant speakers.
It's right outside your door.
And that's why you hear this.
We you're talking about is something that somehow or another is making these
people's houses vibrate like this from miles away.
We don't know of any kind of sound that can do something like that.
What is Woody's last name would,
wouldn't even Doris.
Nobody.
Not Worries.
When we played this sound for Woody Norris,
who is a an acoustical expert,
an engineer,
brilliant genius.
He said,
there's no way the industrial process could make this sound.
He said that the amount of power that would be required to make a sound like
this that would travel that far and not dissipate in the environment is
incredible.
Yeah.
Now,
is this something that has been documented?
Yes.
The sour,
the sound has been documented.
This sound has been documented by the people that live in the town.
It's been documented by the politicians that try to get the explanations for the
citizens,
but if this is a sound that is emanating from Zug island,
it would have to be insanely loud on Zug island.
What people are saying though is that when you're around it,
when you're in the river,
it's not that loud.
It's when you get further away that it's doing things like this,
that it's vibrating people's windows,
vibrating their houses.
There's no known explanation for this and when I talk to this guy who's an audio
expert,
he says that in order to create a power output like that,
you're talking about an insane amount of,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
No that's,
that's an,
that's a really,
really intense sound and it'd be a bummer to have to deal with listening to that
because that is a depressing sound.
That's a sound like in my neighborhood when that sounds starts,
you,
you're not sleeping that night cause someone's having some idiot party until
4:00 AM it sounds like a party.
It sounds like bass speakers it sounds like,
but that would be like your neighbor.
You would have to be like really close for that to be affecting you.
Like
I'm just saying that as a weapon.
If you wanted to,
if you were experimenting with weird forms of weaponry and you could blast that
sound over someone that you were fighting or someone that you wanted to disrupt,
that would do it because that is not a pleasant sound.
Right,
but that I don't,
don't think that that's what anybody's claiming.
I think what they're claiming is that this is a side effect of the use of this
technology.
Ah,
and that most likely what Zug island is,
is some sort of a repeater and that these people are experiencing the sound
outside of the island because of harp.
How close is that to harp?
It's very far from harp,
but what they're saying is that Zug island could be a repeater station.
And the other thing about harp is that harp,
although it's really far away,
the whole purpose of the magnetizing the ionosphere or a rather,
um,
uh,
charging the ionosphere shooting these waves into the ionosphere is so that they
can transmit long distances.
So what the conspiracy theorists believe is that Zug island is some sort of a
repeater station.
So these people who live in Windsor across the river from Zug island are getting
this crazy sound echo thing going on that's rattling their buildings.
No one can explain it.
W W shaking their windows.
I mean,
these people have really freaked out.
And again,
it's not like a couple people we're talking to.
Is this always happening?
It happens quite often and it's dissipated apparently.
And that's where the heart,
the heart proponents believe that what's happening is that they've realized that
they're making the sound now,
so they've turned down the power out.
I don't,
I don't buy it,
man.
I think if you're dealing with like this super advanced Darpa project that can
shoot out,
uh,
things,
the ion is fear.
They're not going to be like,
hey,
let's turn Zug island outside of Detroit into a bass speaker so that everyone
can freak out.
No,
that's not what they're saying.
They're not saying that they're doing it on purpose.
What they're saying is this is a side effect what they're trying to accomplish.
Right.
I don't think anyone is saying that those sky quakes or something they're doing
on purpose.
What they're doing is they're doing some sort of experiments and in doing those
experiments,
one of the side effects is this very strange sound phenomenon.
We're going to go there and see and investigate and talk to some of these people
and find out if this holds up.
But it's a very interesting possibility and these sounds are very unique.
And you know,
very ominous and weird.
Yeah,
they're definitely weird.
I just,
I wonder about the Darpa connection,
but if you go there and actually hear the sound,
I'll be more likely to believe it.
It's the kind of thing where if I knew someone who'd actually heard the sound
themselves,
then I don't know.
It just,
this seems like it seems so easy to fake.
It seems so easy to drop these kinds of things into sound files.
Okay.
Totally.
I totally agree.
The thing is though,
the,
the compelling thing is that all of these folks,
it's well documented that these people have been complaining.
In fact,
when I went through customs,
the guy asked me,
what are you here for?
And I said,
I'm a here to listen to some hum.
And he goes,
oh,
the winds or hum.
Like he goes all,
I go,
what is that?
He goes,
it's probably something going on at Zug island,
like right away the cop that works at the border tells me,
do you feel,
did you hear it?
No,
we didn't hear it.
But we heard a lot of industrial noise.
Right.
And it didn't sound anything like that.
What we heard is like call out are clanging and trucks moving and stuff.
Is there any got like one going on around there or any of them?
No,
no.
That stuff's mostly done on Canada.
Huh?
This is what they,
what they're doing there is they're just creating steel and they're a,
they're mixing the,
the raw elements to create,
create steel and their furnaces.
And there,
there's some,
there's a lot of industrial stuff going on there and it's very high security,
but the high security can easily be explained in that that steel and make,
creating all that steel is very important to the industrial output of the United
States.
It's,
it would be,
uh,
if you were looking for a place to disrupt our economy or to,
to mess up,
you know,
an area that would be something that would do it.
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
You just mentioned that you didn't say there.
It's a high security area.
I think that's really weird.
If this is just supposed to be some toxified industrial island,
I think there is something suspicious about the therapy.
Uh,
the combination of a massive amount of security around a polluted island and
some bizarre Godzilla noise rising up out of the nothingness.
That does seem to indicate that there's more going on there.
Then just making steel.
You're right.
It's very possible.
However,
it's also very possible that what you're dealing with is a high security because
they're creating steel there.
It's incredibly dangerous that working with volatile materials,
they're also probably doing a lot of environmental damage that they wouldn't
want people to investigate or people to shine cameras and expose all this.
I mean it's stinks there but when you go there the water is like greasy with
whatever the hell they're leaking into it.
The guy that we were with was Taz that it floats green.
There's like this glowing green shit that you see in the water so it's not
healthy.
It's definitely,
it's definitely stinks.
It's definitely bad.
We,
we were thinking while we were there,
like were breathing this hand like this is like we're,
we're,
we're taking it fumes.
Yeah.
Detroit is a crazy place man.
When I went and performed at Mark Reilly's comedy castle,
awesome spot.
The Guy who drove me there,
he told me that he used to buy eight balls and go camping,
like who does cocaine camping?
Kid Rock.
Yeah.
I don't think he could blame Detroit or Zug island on that,
but I feel you.
Yeah.
Detroit is the worst person in the world to be a book.
That's the worst place in the world to be a book.
There's 47% illiteracy rate and they call it the first American ruin.
Yeah,
because there's so many at parts of it that are just gone.
Dude,
across from Zug island,
you can get a house in Detroit for $500 we saw them,
they were telling us about it and we saw amazing.
It's incredible.
And you don't want that house.
Well,
no.
It's got toxic mold and it's next to the moaning of Baphomet and the smell.
The smell is horrible.
The smell in the air is,
it's really a shame.
It's a shame.
I know you need steel.
I know that they need it,
but first of all to do it right there in a highly populated area like Detroit
and to do that kind of damage to the environment.
It's just sad.
It's sad,
it seems archaic.
It seems like some shit that they should have figured out how to do better a
long time ago and it kind of makes sense that if you're disrupting the
environment at that level in someplace,
then there's going to be unexplained side effects like some odd noise.
I don't think that is the case.
So this is the thing.
I don't know whether or not the noise and the industrial output or connected.
It makes sense when you look at the sound and the sound is coming from this spot
and you look at the spot and it's a lot of machines moving.
There's a lot of digging in the ground is a lot of making steel Aquaman's razor
would dictate that sound is probably coming from there,
but if these people are to be believed,
these people that are talking about this sound and the rattling of the houses,
it's too much power.
It's too much power.
It's too far away and it's too strange.
It doesn't seem to make sense.
And would it could be is that we're connecting these two,
these two events together.
Right,
but they're,
they're not connected and that all those Zug island is a place where they make
the sound where they were creating or rather,
although Zug island is a place where they make steel that this noise is not
emanating from Zug island,
but in fact it's coming from the sky itself,
from harp.
It's just that people are assuming that Zug island has something to do with it
cause Zog islands gross so that it's just a coincidence.
Super Creepy.
It is creepy.
That sound,
that sound is real is very creepy.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
But you have a good point too,
is that we didn't hear that sound and unless,
unless you,
even if it was like someone you really know,
how do you know whether or not they're really recording that sound or whether
they're getting wacky and getting on their computer and creating it and say,
I'm going to freak everybody out and I'm going to bring some more cause or more
people to this cause more,
more eyes and ears to this plight that we're suffering here when really it's
just normal industrial noise that people are complaining about.
You gotta go there and see and if there's the site,
if you hear the sound,
which I bet you won't,
then it will be interesting.
Why do you bet I won't,
man.
Maybe I will.
Okay.
I don't think there you,
I think the sound of Zug island is the sound of people's neurons frying is they
smoked Detroit level crystal meth in the basements of their $500 crap homes.
Whoa,
whoa.
That's the sound of your brain rotting inside your skull,
bouncing back and forth off the bony walls.
There it is.
Imagine though,
if you were in your house and you're hearing this,
it would be the most annoying thing ever.
And these people say that it could be 24 hours a day and then sometimes they'll
get up in the middle of the night to pee and then we'll hear that sound and
they'll never get back to bed.
They also said that for some reason it seems to correspond with the rain.
They said when it's stormy and rainy,
sometime there's,
there's that sound.
That is where the heart people come in because they think that that's not a
coincidence and they think that the rain itself might be rained that was created
by harp and that that's why these people are saying that whenever it rains and
your thunder,
that's when this sound is more prominent.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's crazy.
As symptom of whether being controlled by harp is low resonant sound sky quakes.
But that makes sense.
Sound.
Think of that.
It's raining out and you hear this sound and you know that big brother is
fucking with the sky and making it rain above your shitty $500 house.
Uh,
that's leaking.
Is it bad enough that I'm here breathing in toxic farts and living in a $500
house.
You guys got to shake my three remaining windows with your stupid sound.
All I want to do is smoke my mat in peace.
There's a physicist named Brooks Agnew who says that he can demonstrate the
effects of harp in a box that he's built and he creates artificial clouds.
He is like one of those MREs.
You know how you buy like a bonsai tree at the mall and they have like the fog
that's flowing out of those are beautiful,
right?
Well that stuff is very similar to clouds.
That vapor,
that water vapor and they puff out at clubs.
Yes.
No,
that's,
that's a smoke.
That's the shit that Michael Braverman likes.
He likes to put that when we're doing promos a fuck,
he likes to fill the air with that shit.
You know.
I love you buddy.
Um,
no.
The um,
it's actually,
uh,
it's vapor.
It's water vapor,
but this guy claims that he,
this device
that can create the same sort of effect by charging the particles that are
inside of this,
this box that he built,
he can actually prove the effects of harp.
Well,
he's saying that there is a correlation between the e cigarette smoke and his
box and actual clouds.
Well,
what clouds are,
is vapor.
It's moisture and it's in a condensed sort of a one.
I should probably actually have a technical explanation because I just ventured
into bullshit.
I do that.
I felt myself doing it,
but I pulled back what a cloud is and I'll never,
I have no idea what it is.
A visible mass of liquid droplets or frozen crystals made of water or various
chemicals suspended in the atmosphere above the surface of a planetary body.
Okay,
so now you know,
so it's,
it is clouds with his guys creating as essentially the same thing as clouds.
He's using moisture and he's using this machine that does something and it
creates e-cigarettes,
e-cigarettes,
or an ionizer that creates water vapor that has nicotine infused into the vapor.
Just like Stephen Dorff.
Awesome commercials.
Now.
Hey guys,
come on guys to take back our freedom saying that if this is like if a giant
Stephen Dorff,
we're breathing east segregate cigarette smoke over America,
it would be cloud.
And if you had a machine you could zap that the clouds and make a tornado that
take Stephen Dorff away like the house and the wizard of Oz where it lands on
the witch.
Yes.
Just like that.
And then Darpa would finally have done something amazing for the world.
That would be the second best thing they did since the Internet.
Look,
Stephen Dorff was awesome and blade.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you need to step.
I stepped played one is the best blade ever.
Stephen Dorff was the,
the the bad guy and he was amazing.
She's amazing.
Great.
So shut it.
I'm sorry Steven to laugh.
Please apologize.
He's too easy.
Stephen Dorff.
Steven making our cloud.
Stephen Dorff is the Nickelback of actors.
It's too easy to pick on him.
It's not fair.
It's rude.
It's cheap and it's rude.
He's the rape joke of actors.
We just need to stop.
He just stopped the Stephen Stephen Dorff happened to be flipping through
channels right now and heard that he's going for his pistol.
Well don't shoot me as long as you going to shoot yourself.
Death is inevitable with my friend.
Okay,
but murder,
you don't want to murder charge like yourself,
Steven,
don't do it.
You're going to be fun.
So look,
I don't,
I think that it's a interesting thing.
I the box.
I would wonder if the clouds in this box are identical to the clouds.
It they are actually floating overland because I think like what you just did
definition that you just read it.
Ice Crystals,
chemicals.
This is just like ionized vapor.
So I wonder if it looks like it's actually better liquid droplets.
It's a visible mass of liquid droplets or frozen crystal sugar water.
So it's close enough for various chemicals.
Like there can be a toxic cloud too.
That's not not water droplets.
Chemicals can actually form toxic
clouds.
And he's saying that by shooting some form of electricity into this,
this is what he says.
So we're going to say,
and we're not going to say we've already seen,
so we're going to change shirts and we're going to go right into this because
this guy's an idiot.
Okay,
awesome.
So I go to visit this physicist named Brooks Agnew and Brooks Agnew has a box
that he's got this artificial clouds that he's created with this Mr Machine.
Yeah.
And he believes that he has this machine that can dissipate the clouds.
So we go and do the experiments.
First of all,
here's red flag number one.
We walk in the door and his friend,
uh,
there's a photo of a,
an Indian man with white paint on his face.
So I say,
what's up with this dude?
And he said,
he went,
underwent an amazing transformation of his body 10 years ago,
and now he no longer needs food or water.
And I go,
no,
he didn't.
And I just walk out of the room.
I go,
no,
he didn't.
He goes,
you have to meet this guy.
Go,
no,
I don't.
No,
I don't have to meet him.
And that guy eats,
stop,
get away from me.
And like I knew right away we'd made a horrible mistake cause this is the dude
he's partying with.
Okay.
It's not the scientist and the scientist buddy.
So we go in that Brooks has this machine and in this machine he's got the clouds
and he's like,
no,
I'm going to turn it on.
And so he turns it on and uh,
we're,
we're seeing the clouds dissipate fairly rapidly and we're like,
hmm,
this is interesting.
The clouds have dissipated fairly rapidly.
But then we noticed this motherfuckers got a crack in the door so the clouds are
sneaking out of his door.
Okay.
So now we take over the cracks of the door.
We turn it on again.
Now this,
it doesn't dissipate at all.
Right.
It's just sort of hovers there.
But there's some weird funnels like coming off of it.
Well,
it does seem to have an effect.
Well then we opened the door and touch it and it's hot.
So this stupid machine that he claims is changing the ionosphere and the tube
and then making the weather manipulate.
It's just hot.
It's just a big stupid hot electrical box.
And when it gives off heat,
heat rises and it,
you know,
it goes through this stupid fake clouds.
So nothing so not,
but here's what's crazy.
Not only did this guy thought this,
but that this guy thought this enough to build a machine and that he did this
and said,
this is so good.
It needs to be on TV.
Yeah,
that's fun though.
Going crazy.
I'd love to go that crazy.
Do you know how fun that would be?
Seriously constructing a weather machine in your house?
Yeah.
That will be a blast.
So he's enjoying life and he somehow his,
whether machines summoned the TV crew
and you know what's really crazy magic.
He's a white guy.
Hello?
Who'd a thought it's,
you never see white guys with these unfounded claims.
It's a really rare that you see a bunch of white guys in their late forties
early fifties possibly into their sixties hosts divorce or post divorce,
just eaten alive by depression.
Like,
yeah.
You know,
waking up and spitting out pieces of their teeth from grinding all night long
and then going to work on your weather machine is your tears disrupt your
experiment when you contemplate how your wife left you because you wouldn't stop
talking about harp.
And then you call your friend over the Tarion who knows a dude who actually is
an heir at Terrion.
Just each air doesn't have water,
doesn't have food that makes sense to you.
This is the guys hanging out at your house and you go,
what do you think you to help me put this together?
I think you're onto some amazing work.
Amazing.
You're doing amazing work.
So they put together this stupid thing and it doesn't work.
And,
and you flew out to that?
No,
I drove.
This was an,
luckily it was in California,
but not only did we drive,
but this is how stupid we are.
The Guy said there was a mistake with the experiment we want.
He wants to do it again.
So he had them do it again.
So the,
the camera crew went back a second time.
And guess what happened the second time?
Fucking nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
Nothing's going to happen.
You knew nothing was going to happen.
You wanted the camera back again like you,
this guy probably has seen the secret like a thousand times and he thinks that
if he really truly believes that this is a weather machine,
then it becomes a weather machine.
Yeah.
Or something.
By the way,
the next season of this show,
you are going to be riddled with trolls.
Who realized that you guys will come out to anything.
It's too late.
What do you do?
Just email the Scifi channel and Joe Rogan shows up at your house.
If you've farted in a box.
Dude,
it's way too late for that.
Did you see the photo that I tweeted yesterday of me,
uh,
with this stupid fucking apparatus on my head?
Cause some asshole claims that this stupid apparatus was going to uh,
detect electricity that comes off of my eyeballs.
Look at this.
This,
this fuck had gotten me to where this,
this guy got me to wear this.
And inside this thing does goggle inside the goggle is like a sensor.
And the sensor reads the electricity coming off your eyeballs.
So he's talking to all these scientific terms and he's got a degree in Canada.
And so he tells me he's,
he tells me that this device measures of the electricity coming off your
eyeballs and that theoretically you could feel this electricity on the back of
your head scientifically explaining the psychic phenomenon that a lot of people
believe in,
which is that people can tell when people are looking at the back of their head.
So this fuck head gets me to put on this stupid thing.
I got glue all over my head.
Lucky I'm bald because then I just have to clean my head.
If that was in my hair,
I'd be pissed.
Especially if had some beautiful like Joey Lawrence and the nineties hair,
just something flowing,
you know,
and then saw this gooey shit.
A boy can dream.
So anyway,
I got these goggles on and the goggles have a sensor in and he shows me that on
this EKG.
So what it's called Eeg,
Kanji,
whatever it's called.
He shows me EEG.
Electroencephalogram.
Yeah.
He shows me on this computer that the e g f set up is reading all the electrodes
on my head,
but also reading the one that's in front of my eye.
And then it's a very similar signal,
thus indicating that electricity is coming off of your eyeball,
like the evil eye in scientific form.
So,
so,
um,
I say,
hmm.
So I look at his test and I go,
did you ever try just putting it on your hand?
And then I just put it on my hand and it's the same thing,
this same signal.
And the only time it's not the same signal is when it's shaking because I'm
going,
it's the same fucking signal you made me put glue on my head and I'm holding
your wacky space goggles that you think can measure eyeball raise.
You'll fuck head look what you've done to me.
I'm mad.
And I said to him,
I said,
how did you get again,
same thing.
How did you get on TV with this?
How did it Kinda does and how has this,
not just a dumb idea that you fucked around with with your friends,
but you got so far that you went to her producer and said,
well this is what I can do.
And he went,
I like your Moxie.
I think this is going to really happen.
I think this is going to be an amazing segment once they show that you are
correct and that you can shoot raise from your eyes and then I can detect this,
oh this is going to be fantastic stuff.
You could probably be on Doctor Oz after this show.
Wow.
But no,
it's just another white dude with unfounded claims in his 50s and access to
aluminum foil.
He had aluminum foil and head glue.
Has anybody looked into the correlation between starting to like aluminum foil
and going insane?
It's like cats they make out of,
I mean that's literally wear tinfoil hat theory came from somewhere along the
lines.
So many fuckheads had tin foil hats on,
but people actually came up with that expression.
Like if you say that expression,
the tin foil hat brigade,
people know exactly what you're saying.
You don't have to say conspiracy theorist.
He say,
oh,
he's one of those tin foil hat wearing motherfuckers,
and then the conversation's over.
If you aren't using aluminum foil for cooking,
there's a 15% chance you've gotten and saying,
what is,
what is it about aluminum?
And that's the shift that people look forward to.
It's,
yeah.
I can show people that always claiming this plane aluminum.
It's all aluminum with these guys.
You know what's crazy is the ground is mostly aluminum.
A lot of God damn aluminum up there.
Apparently it's super cheap.
Jamaica
is a source of aluminum.
Jamaica is a source of aluminum.
Yeah.
They put,
well,
it's apparently according to scientists,
it's one of the most common minerals known to man.
It's also what you put into an apple.
If you've lost your pipe,
you can smoke weed from an apple on aluminum foil.
Aluminum foil pipes.
Yeah.
That's the foil though,
buddy.
It's not the same thing.
It's a mineral that's in the ground.
You're talking nothing crazy.
Foil isn't made of aluminum.
Yes,
it's made of aluminum.
I don't want to talk about it too long or we'll both go insane.
If it's aluminum foil,
just aluminum or does it have anything else that's mixed into it and heat it
down?
It's kind of fascinating that they can make metal that you can just repeat here
is the downwards slippery slope.
Well it's kind of cool.
Aluminum foil is cool.
Like you could take an ass hole and you could wrap that apple up in it.
Like did you take a piece of food and wrap it up in the internet or a friend?
Turn her under an android.
Don't do that because chicks are always going to think that you really want an
android and then we're going to make them insecure.
I do it to ever make a girl do dress up bro.
Who says
like,
I tried to take away your favorite thing in life.
Go like,
who the fuck are you?
It's like saying never put salt on French fries.
How far do you take dress up though?
Do you take it all the way to furry?
Like at a certain point in time?
It's weird.
Like there's a certain amount of dress up and this society that we allow,
like you're allowed to wear a toupee through the metal detector at the airport,
but they will make you take off a fake beard if you have,
like if you've walked through and you've got to look at Abraham Lincoln beer
with a chin strap and they're looking at you like we can get this motherfucker
this,
you know,
like a little tie behind your head.
A big stupid fake beard.
They're like,
you have to take that officer.
They'll allow you to wear a toupee if as long as it's like pinned down somehow.
Oh,
once how K to finds out about that.
They know now it's over.
There's a certain amount of dress up that you're allowed to do.
Sure.
Right.
So you are allowed to wear a ball gag,
but you can't dress like a mascot.
You know I'm not,
I'm not against of,
but I'm saying you can't be a furry me know anybody.
If you're a furry,
if you'd like dressing up like a mascot,
open up the front hatch and having sex with each other,
you fucking crazy.
Right.
If you're someone who likes to dress up,
like a girl likes to wear leather or she likes you to tie her up,
she's just a freak.
But if she wants to dress like bugs bunny and she wants you to come and her
face,
that's crazy.
That's a friend.
Yeah.
What is,
what are the fuck is the furry thing with the mascot?
I don't know.
That is,
that is really creepy in the furry stuff I can kind of understand,
but like it's when people are like putting like holes into their e or stuffed
animals and fucking them where stuff gets weird.
Yeah.
That gets really weird.
Like a fleshlight in the giant Barney the dinosaur.
Thank you so much for tuning in to Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
We're going to cut to commercial.
Well,
this is going to be released as a podcast too.
That's what we're doing.
We're taking an audio form of this and we're going to put it out as a podcast so
it's,
there's no,
nothing will be lost here.
Oh,
that's exciting.
Yeah.
Great.
If TV was advanced enough to recognize that no one's being offended anymore by
anything.
Yeah.
Right.
At a certain point in time they would have to,
well,
they have to accept that when podcasts,
I'd having the same exact commercials and they're pretty close is television
then they're going
to have to accept that.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
I,
I can't wait for African Mama in their hand.
You know,
I just,
uh,
heard Al Madrigal actually,
did this interviewer,
they asked him what his least favorite song was and he said that Macklemore song
about thrift shops and he said,
the reason is like,
it's like having to explain to your daughter what jizzing is or what,
you know what I mean?
Like when your kids listen to it or like there's apparently a song in the
Macklemore's song about pissing on,
uh,
what's is it,
who's the rapper?
He pissed on the 15 year old.
I have no idea.
Kelly R.
Kelly.
There's apparently some reference to our Kelly and the song and magical is
pointing out how like it puts you in a weird place when your kid is asking who
are Kelly is and why they're talking about him pissing his bed or what?
Well,
why?
That's ridiculous.
Why is he playing that kind of music around his fucking kid?
His kids.
Kids love it.
Kids listened to that.
How old are his kids?
I don't know if they're young.
If they're under 15 they're young.
That's rude.
Well I think kids can get to this music.
It's not like you're,
you're playing it for them.
It's like they find it.
They find it online.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like my,
your dad's porn.
Right.
It's not like your dad's like come here,
look at this pussy.
It's like you found the porn.
Right.
So kids find that's a PR.
I mean I think his point.
What apps to a strip club w with thrift shops would that have to do with
sheriff's house?
What do you mean?
That's the name of the song.
The name and the name of the songs.
Thrift shop.
It's just,
he made the point he made that.
I thought it was interesting.
It's like,
yeah,
I guess if I had kids it would put me in a weird predicament if I'm always
having to explain to them like adult concepts cause I have to either decide
between lying to them or like telling them the truth.
And that's a weird place to get into with a kid
and the now in 2013 that's not really necessary anymore because by the time a
kid gets to be 13 years old,
right,
they've seen it all.
Yes.
That's true to me.
Remember how much shit you saw that your parents had no idea.
Like did you ever see any like faces of death stuff?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean we saw a lot of shit that you,
you didn't,
no one ever saw before us.
Well yeah,
right.
But we never see,
I mean the stuff that kids are seeing now is just,
yeah,
we were the first generation c we were the first people with VCRs.
See our,
our family,
like our parents did not grow up with VCRs.
Right.
So when they grew up,
either saw something on TV or you didn't and you didn't get to see it again.
If you don't,
the only time you saw it again as if they played it again and they never played
anything again.
They'd played a few movies like every now and then they'll take King Kong is
going to be on again.
You'd know when you'd wait for it.
Right.
They have to watch it as it was happening.
So our generation was the first generation that had tapes and we would get
something and stick it in something and press play when we wanted.
So we were the first people to,
to take that next level information thing and right.
And what did we do with it faces a death barnyard Betty like some of the most
fucked up heinous things ever.
Like within a few years
of making VHS tapes,
they had a whole series of faces of death and that's when the UFC came out.
And like all these different things like the early UFC is,
we're like that.
Like a lot of people thought that was what you were watching wasn't a martial
art.
They thought what you were watching was just like some faces of death type
thing.
Like,
oh my God,
but watching cage fighting.
This is crazy.
It became a martial arts.
Sure.
Beginning.
It was like more of a freak show than anything.
Yup,
but the kids today,
that's a,
that's a joke.
The kids today,
like a beheading.
What is that?
That's another thing I heard that foreign yard Betty
for teenagers,
anal sex is second base.
Like they're fucking each other in the ass
soul before they're having vaginal sex.
No.
Yeah.
That's like a night of making out.
You probably end up sticking your cock and a girl's ass.
No.
[inaudible] are you doing this and what it on a chat room or is this is when it,
whenever someone says to me,
the teenage kids,
teenage kids are having more anal sex than ever.
Yeah.
I always say,
why you even research and teenage kids and angels and anal sex like,
oh,
let me Google search history.
Five years.
I didn't pop up once.
Ain't kids and anal sex kids.
Only if we had this conversation.
Teenagers and anal sex.
Those are kids.
If you Google search anal sex teen right now,
you will get more results than moon landing.
I think they mean like 18 and 19 but that's not what you mean when you're
talking about kids.
We're not talking about porn.
You're talking about kids and having sex.
Here's a real shocker.
14 high school.
Let me just send a bolt of terror through the country.
Kids are fucking in highschool.
Guys knows I did.
You people are not ready for this.
You should slowly work this in.
Yeah.
You shouldn't just say,
Hey,
guess what?
Your kids are fucking,
what if someone's been in denial?
What have they just been in denial?
Just Holman Christian songs as they walk around the house thinking the kids at
school,
just learning.
Meanwhile,
she's just someone's balls deep in her ass and a dumpster right now.
Yeah,
they're hide behind a cardboard box.
She's getting fucked so hard.
She's using telekinetic to like live cars
and that sound is the Windsor hum is filling the sky.
Oh.
Her eyes are rolled behind her head.
She's squirting.
Oh
yeah,
whoa.
Got squatch all over go watch.
Yeah,
well that happens man.
Kids are fucking,
my mom bought me a box of condoms and now he's in the 10th grade.
She gave me a box of condoms cause she knew I was going to be fucking,
she's like,
just wear these condoms.
She'd seen my girlfriend.
Well she knew your girlfriend was a dirty girl.
Not just dirty,
but like albino is like swampy.
Like she was like that.
You should have to wear it.
Come on now.
I know.
In the swamp.
That was your first girlfriend.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
Albino and swell.
That sounds like a Stephen Lynch movie.
David David Lynch.
Stephen Lynch is a singer.
Ah,
that is a David Lynch.
Movio translucent skin blue vein.
Listen,
a swamp.
Blue van.
[inaudible] long cliteracy you don't know whether you say something or not
that's going to deal with this.
It's just,
it's not
quite a finger,
but I mean it's definitely a finger that's been bitten off like a nub.
It's enough.
I wouldn't say it's a finger.
It's like a finger that lost a bar fight.
When do you talk about the length of a girl's clutter?
It's like what do you think immediately after you get done fucking her to your
friends?
I mean if it's,
it depends on how big it is.
If it's totally normal,
it never comes up.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I've never discussed the length of my life by my wife's cliteracy.
You should totally normal.
I'll tell you right now,
there's nothing special about it.
It's a regular vagina.
It looks great.
It's awesome.
Great good design.
You don't need to fuck with it.
It doesn't need pin stripes,
but the,
the crazy ones,
the ones that are weird,
it's like what is that like why is there an evolutionary advantage for looking
like a Mousse with a gunshot hole in it?
Oh his.
What is it about?
Is it about some of them
that vary so widely,
but at least with a woman like it doesn't,
I don't think they vary so much and well I guess they do vary in size,
but it doesn't have any like social stigma attached to it and in fact have a
girl has a,
a very small and a welcoming tight little area that's probably better than a big
crazy loose thing.
So it works the opposite for them than it does for us.
For us,
it's as evolutionary advantage to have a large penis.
I see what you're big Rasputin looking.
We looked at Rasputin's yesterday.
We were looking at it.
Oh yeah,
I've seen Rasputin's cock jar.
I heard his story that Rasputin was at a bar and telling people that he was rice
Buton and they're like,
whatever,
you're not recipe it.
And he's like,
I'll show you I'm fucking recipe.
And then he like pulls his job tree trunk cock out and like,
yeah,
you're,
you're Rasputin it's in a jar.
It's 11 inches soft.
It's a big jar too.
It's like that would not fit in a regular mayonnaise size jar.
Costco Jar.
Yeah.
He would have to get a Costco Jelly bean jar if they have a special caulk jar.
It's just for Cox.
I said,
yeah,
but his cock was like,
that is a,
that caucus is a bad thing.
Like it didn't,
that cock is a um,
uh,
a death hammer.
Like that's a thing that you can even still now it's how ever many years it's
been in that jar.
You can still feel evil coming off of it.
Yeah.
Maybe you can feel evil.
I feel a bunch of player haters,
a chopped off of giant God's Dick.
Oh wait,
he's just a regular dude with a big deck slinging dicks are given out bubble gum
and having a great time in Russia,
which by the way sucks.
It's freezing cold.
Everyone's an asshole.
They're all the other ass kicked by the Mongols and then it never recovered.
So they're up there freezing their dicks off and one guy comes along just
swinging a monster hog and having a good old time.
And he hypnotizes all the girls in the area with his Dick and his Willie ways
and he winds up being a superstar amongst all of these women,
including the Zarina,
the czar's wife.
He was given the fucking King of the lands wife the Dick.
That's fuck yeah,
son.
Yeah,
he was hanging around all those chicks.
He's one of those dudes like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
He's hanging around you.
He's fucked
you.
Here's the thing,
you can't cheat with rescued because like if you're in bed with your wife and
you look down at her vagina and it looks like a sink hole,
like you fuck trus fusion,
you asshole like you're hit.
Vaginas would look like craters after experiencing that.
That this is like,
it's a cock the size of the width of an encyclopedia.
But regular vaginas have babies go through them,
which are much bigger than a cock and I snap like they snap right back.
If your wife gave birth the next day when you be able to tell dude,
yes,
but Rasputin's Dick was not nine pounds.
I did have,
these are nine pounds,
dude.
Vaginas are crazy.
Oregon's,
they stretch out and pop out a baby and then snap back shut like a clam.
They don't snap back shut like I am.
It's a slow snapback.
No,
they stitch up stitch up any tearing.
They snapped back like it's like a slow congealing.
Right.
How do you know now?
I've been through it three times.
Trust me.
My wife's vagina is excellent.
They stitch that shit up there.
There's some tearing and I think when they,
when they stitch it up,
they have that Benny Hill music plan
because they know that you got to do it again.
He's just going to get pregnant again.
What would that one more time.
All right.
Damn man.
It is weird though.
How nature did didn't build in the,
uh,
it's weird that that's,
that there is a tear.
It's funny that it's,
it's not built so that it just pops a baby out without there being damaged or
pain.
Well,
that's how chimps do you ever see chimps give birth now pull up,
see if you could see a chimp giving birth.
See,
we've got a video online.
The way chimps give birth as they just reach in and pull it out and that's it
and they're done.
They just reach in,
pull the baby out,
put it down,
clean it off a little bit and they don't come out helpless either mean obviously
they need their mother but they're not like us.
We come out like incredibly help us for a long time.
We can't even walk,
we can't do shit.
We can't even control our own
heads.
We just fall forward.
We are,
our heads are so big that we have to be born like way earlier in the process
than other animals and our minds are so complex that the gestation process takes
a long time here.
What this that's the baby.
She leans back like she's in an old school,
Traci lords movie and she just grabs a hold of the hair on the baby and she's
just squeezing it out.
It doesn't seem like she's in any pain at all.
And she's,
she just squeezing on her very casual,
her vagina and a,
the baby heads is slowly popping out and she's just trying to figure out when to
get a grip on it and the males coming over to check it out.
There's no doctors,
not a sanitary environment.
I terrible mural,
not a Filipino lady to be seen.
Try going to a hospital and not seeing a Filipino.
Good luck.
I don't know why,
but that is true.
They just make awesome nurses.
They're drawn to hospitals like math and she's like sitting there while this a
baby's coming out of her body.
It just,
the,
the evolutionary process is so strange and when you see like a life coming out
of a life,
it's one of the weirdest things you get.
I've seen it several times now.
You know,
twice in person and it's a,
it's a trip man.
It's really a trip.
I'm assuming that's her mate,
but I don't know like the other ones like watching,
he's concerned it's insurance.
She's most likely a whore and she probably fucked every champion the whole
group.
But she's just trying to look at this.
Wow.
She's,
she's just bending over and he's checking it out now and she's like,
what do you see?
Flexible.
Yeah.
She's like,
what do you think?
Is it ready?
And he just know,
hmm.
Wow.
And she's like,
it's so weird.
Like I'll get it now.
She's squeezing them out there.
Whoa.
This is crazy plot.
Oh Damn.
That needs to be an animated Gif file.
Like the moment the baby comes out and the puddle that creates and the,
the,
the male is it?
Of course she's eating the placenta,
the ether percent there.
Right away.
I've heard that you should do that.
That is a fucking trip.
That is it.
Such a trip.
What's really true and so sweet.
They're both licking the little chin.
What's really a trip is that chimpanzees are a,
some sort of a distant relative of us.
And at one point in time,
our ancient ancient ancestors would probably very similar to this and that
something happened and we kept going and we went from that to this.
Well,
that that seems a lot,
a lot sweeter and more natural than doing it in some sterile room.
People wearing weird clothes.
Well that's not sterile.
I mean that's not natural.
That was in a zoo,
dude.
That was on a slab of concrete.
How,
how natural is it for a chimp to give birth on concrete?
Absolutely.
Right.
I don't know why I said kind of fucked up about the baby coming out on that hard
surface.
Like if they were in jungle,
the jungle
soft.
It's like when we were in Seattle looking for big for it to set the ground.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's very soft.
Like you could shoot out a kid there with no problem.
Yeah.
If you heard about the father Zod and the source family,
do you know about this?
What father's Od and the source family and the source family?
I can't.
It's a cult and I can't remember if it's Manson or father's side,
but in these calls,
you know the lemon,
of course they give birth after they get impregnated.
Right.
And this guy,
as I recall,
I'm trying to think of it's Manson.
I got my coat leaders make step.
I can't remember which one but in one of these look up father Zod umbilical
cord,
that classic search
we NSA is knocking on my door as we speak.
Please.
Hmm,
no,
it's just as documentary where it's,
it was the point is that a woman gave birth and I can't remember if it's Manson
her father's out,
but one of them chewed the umbilical cord off like bid it bit through.
It is probably your father is odd cause I never heard that story.
Yeah,
it's father's Zach because you'd hear about it with Manson.
It was father's out,
but it kind of makes sense.
You know
now looking at that video of that chimpanzee given birth on the floor,
that zoo like seeing that animal,
how alien that is to you or I,
but not that much.
I mean it is alien,
it's an animal.
But it's kind of human like and a lot of ways sure.
Aware,
intelligent,
paying attention to what's going on,
you know,
and the,
the two arms and two legs thing.
Yeah.
It's so similar.
So it's so strange and it's so strange to think that somewhere in the past
that's if you believe in evolution,
which you shouldn't,
but that's somewhere in the past allegedly,
we were something like that and that we were all sort of,
uh,
developing along a similar line.
And one of us became,
you and I,
one of us became a Homosapien,
became a human being.
Right.
But there's other ones.
This is the Homo Floresiensis,
that little hobbit man and the island of Flores.
Yeah.
There's neanderthal.
Notice how I said tall because I'm very educated.
I thought,
no,
that's the old way I'm current.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I how I judge a man by the way.
He pronounces neanderthals.
You're tall.
You're kind of an asshole.
I'm an asshole.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
That's how I'm Anderson.
Cooper says neanderthal because you're right.
God dammit.
I'm getting neanderthal
southern wrong with that.
The underdog.
It sounds better.
Anyway,
over the job
I would have Flores,
ma'am,
it's a three foot tall hobbit man.
Really fascinating thing that until a few a few years ago,
they thought it was just horse shit.
They really had no idea that 10,000 plus years ago there was this little tiny
man running around and running around the same time there was grown humans like
you and I like or rather our size.
Um,
even though we're both short the,
um,
the question has always been,
are there others?
And the question always been if
there were others,
where the fuck would they be hiding?
Right.
If there's an aisle,
well,
they didn't find out about gorillas and to the early 19 hundreds,
but the deal,
that's sort of a disingenuous thing to say though,
because the world of the 19 hundreds doesn't even remotely resemble the world
that we see today.
Right.
Because the world that we see today,
we,
we pretty much have a good account of what's alive in almost every place.
Absolutely.
Might've missed a few spots.
Like there's some weird shit,
like every now and then they'll find like a weird frog and New Guinea or a D in
Vietnam.
It's been hiding in the jungle and they're like,
whoa.
But where people are not willing to go is with another intelligent animal.
You could say you found a previously unknown deer in Vietnam,
which did happen recently.
Sure.
A couple of years ago.
In fact,
big animal,
like a size of a whitetail deer,
completely different species they weren't aware of before,
but it lives in the jungle and you go,
well,
I could kind of see that happen,
but the idea of an intelligent thing,
that's where people won't budge.
The idea of an intelligent ape like human,
like thing,
another branch on the evolutionary chain of lower hominids to human being
another branch.
Yeah.
It's interesting how in the news when you hear about,
they discovered a new lizard in the Amazon.
It's like,
oh,
whatever.
Who Cares?
I'll think about that for four seconds.
It's not interesting at all.
I don't even want to look at a picture of it.
Right.
But if they came out and said,
we found an intelligent apelike being living in its own civilization and the
depths of the rain forest,
that would make news forever.
Yeah.
So change the world.
Yeah,
we're,
we're so,
it is interesting that we do,
it's not a surprise any other species that gets discovered out in the great vast
wilderness that still exist,
but for whatever reason,
we immediately disregard the idea that there could be another form of super
advanced primate.
Others.
And they found primates very recently.
In fact,
they found this little pygmy primate.
It's a little tiny little monkey thing.
It's really small though.
So we don't really give a shit about it now.
It's like,
so what?
You found a tiny monkey,
but if you found a seven foot tall monkey,
they would go ho Lee shit.
What is it
that if it didn't,
they just fine,
but didn't they just find something akin to that?
Like,
didn't you?
Uh,
what did you call,
it's called the shit.
It's some very rare carnivorous apes.
Yes.
Pull up an image of the Bondo ape.
You could see one that got shot and you can see this animal and this is an
animal that,
um,
up until I think 1996 they didn't have any photos of it.
There's a wildlife photographer from Switzerland named Carl Armand and Carl
Armaun went to,
that's a really old picture,
right?
Isn't that a picture from like the early 19 hundreds it could be a,
I think that is,
I think that was a picture where it was a huge chimpanzee and they didn't know
why that,
that,
that chimp was,
was so big.
That's the one that got shot.
Now this is a,
a chimpanzee that's way larger.
The other TV doesn't work.
Yeah,
it's off.
Okay.
For a reason.
Yeah.
Okay.
That CBC,
that thing.
Yeah,
but you can just look at it,
man.
No,
you don't have to look at it.
See,
you can see that thing behind you.
Just look at it and just this not looking for happy.
That's like,
you don't want to stumble onto that thing.
They shot it,
but that's that.
It looks like a gorilla.
It doesn't look like a chimpanzee and it looks like a gorilla.
And it's called the Bondo ape,
and up until the 1990s this thing was just a,
it was a myth.
It was a legend.
It's an enormous chimpanzee and the locals in the Congo,
they say there's two types of chimps.
There's the tree beaders and the lion killers and the tree beaters are these
smaller chimps that who swing from tree to tree.
The lion killers are these bondo apes that are giant champs that sleep on the
ground like gorillas.
Right.
They're not scared of anything.
They sleep on the ground.
They didn't have to hide in the trees.
Like to this day,
the reason why people have their master bedroom on the top floor,
it was the whole,
the whole chimpanzee idea,
or you get to the the highest branches where you're the most protected and
that's where you rest.
That's crazy.
I never knew that,
but yeah,
you're absolutely right.
What the house,
it's at the top of the building.
That's the best part of the building.
Just the leopards can't get there.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
Well,
these animals that are so big that they're not even scared,
they don't go to the top of the tree.
So probably the branches would break cause they're probably several hundred
pounds.
I mean the,
they're not like a small chimpanzee.
You mean they're like three plus maybe even four.
Right.
So you're dealing with an enormous chimpanzee that occasionally will walk
upright.
There's phone,
there's a camera trap photo of one.
So if you can pull that up though,
Karl Armaun camera trap chimpanzee,
you can see this thing walking upright and they're six feet tall.
Right?
It's enormous.
So you're talking about chimp,
that's four inches taller than me and it's huge.
Just gigantic muscles.
Probably as strong as all like a thousand pound man.
Yeah.
And they got a video of one eating a fucking leper.
And here's the important note in relation to Sasquatch,
they just found the thing,
1990 you have a six foot chimp that walks up right?
Wandering around in the,
in the,
in,
in nature.
And no one's discovered it until just now.
No one's gotten proof of it till just now.
Yeah.
Look at this thing.
This is the picture of it walking.
It's walking upright.
That's a shit resolution.
It's hard to see in that photo,
but that thing is walking hunched over and upright and it's six feet tall.
Those are devil chimps.
Their heads look like skulls.
Look at their heads.
They were enormous.
Well,
they have a crest on their head like a gorilla that the only other chimpanzees
and the only other a primate besides gorillas,
they have a crest on their head like that.
So they thought initially before they ran DNA tests on them,
they thought initially that they were a hybrid between a gorilla and a
chimpanzee,
but now it appears that it's just a subset of this chimpanzee if he's a species.
Yeah,
so to me that that is one of the things that exist in the world that made me
think it's possible that there is a Yeti or a Sasquatch because w how could you
not discover something that's that size,
that that is that unique?
Why wouldn't,
if something like that can hide from modern society for so long after the
invention of cameras,
after the invention of helicopters,
then why couldn't there be something like a Sasquatch or a Yeti or something
like that?
Still out?
Yeah,
they're,
yeah.
They found the gorilla,
like we said in the early 19 hundreds.
It didn't find this for almost a hundred years after that.
Right.
And we know the chimpanzees are intelligent.
We,
but we also know that they're not nearly as intelligent as people.
I don't know if that thing was hiding from people or it was just in a place that
was so remote and so hard to get to.
The Congo is enormous.
Right?
I mean,
it's really impossible for us to wrap our heads around it.
It's like almost as wide as the United States is.
It's huge,
I think is that they're correct.
Google that place.
Um,
it's,
it's enormous.
It's,
it's many,
many,
many millions of square miles.
Right?
And so the,
it's not without outside the realm of possibility that this almost impenetrable
jungle can hold a bunch of different animals in it.
But the difference being this animal looks like another animal that we already
knew about.
That's why it's not that crazy.
Right?
Big Foot is a totally new thing.
You know,
you're saying there's an animal that no one's ever found.
Look at the size of that.
That's the Congo.
Geez,
Louise from top to bottom.
It's almost the same height as,
uh,
as the United States.
That's giant.
And that's all jungle.
So the,
um,
the idea that this is a big foot though,
that's where it gets a real squirrely because you're talking about a totally
undiscovered primate that lives around people and gets real close to people,
but never when they have their cameras out.
Never a picture that is,
are a picture like what you just showed me at the Bondo ape.
Never a picture or video where you,
it's indisputable.
It's,
it's very similar to you,
fos or goes through any other thing like that.
It's,
every picture is easily discounted or at least,
or not quite good enough.
Right?
Not quite good enough.
Every photos like,
man,
that might be Sasquatch.
Alright.
I don't know.
It's hard to tell
[inaudible] not a single camera trap.
Do you want any camera traps are out there now hunters used them,
they set them up on trails and they put these things out there.
And what they do is they take a photo.
Either they have two ways of doing it.
Either they take a photo every three or four seconds or five seconds or whatever
you said it,
four or they,
they act on motion.
So when they see something walking in front of them,
a flash will go off and they take a photo.
So they will,
it'll deal either be night vision and the work at night,
or they'll work on a flash system.
Sure.
None of these things let me ever caught us up
and I play Sasquatch advocate ears,
please.
Okay,
so you've,
you actually pointed out this,
these tigers that were on some other island that on an island that like evolved
in sense,
it's lions actually.
Why Africa?
So relentless enemies.
National Geographic special.
Okay.
So
why I point that only because we've seen cases where evolution
happens rapidly.
It doesn't happen over the course of,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of years.
Sometimes it seems to happen in a really fast way and there would be an
evolutionary advantage for a being like a Sasquatch to avoid humans.
In fact,
there's an evolutionary advantage to any creature avoiding humans because we
like to eat things.
We love eating.
Things are turning them into our slaves.
So there's an evolutionary advantage to staying the hell away from us.
So in that way,
uh,
if a primate somehow evolved in the same way we did and we've made super
computers and robots and space shuttles,
if for whatever reason,
something similar to us,
wouldn't know it,
a different direction,
which is the direction of being closer to nature tied into the earth.
Part of that evolution would be avoiding the crazy ball monkeys.
They eat you,
they enslave you,
they will have sex with you if they can stay away from them.
So in that way it could make sense that a super advanced primary,
it will be able to smell a human scent on a device like that.
And they just stay,
stay away from it.
They avoid it.
Why?
Why couldn't there be some new reclusive primate animals run away from me all
the time?
It's possible.
It is possible.
And when you say it like that,
you bring up a lot of not of awesome points.
I mean,
if you were going to be a primate that was super intelligent and figured out how
to live in the woods,
the smartest thing to do,
it'd be don't let people know about you ever stay away and mean.
The real question is how smart are these things?
Now,
if you talk to the,
the,
let's,
let's give a broad spectrum of wackiness and she talked to the,
for the UFO hunters,
the wackiest of wacky thank their people.
They think that they are the spiritual beings that are very human,
like inform,
like they think they have a human face is just a very dark face and that they're
just covered in hair and they were a type of wild human that lives in the woods.
Okay.
I mean there's,
there's some really,
there's a,
there's a lot of variation in what they believe that they're capable of.
Sure.
But ultimately they're talking about a giant bipedal ape that no one's taken a
picture of.
Sure.
It's gets a little sketchy.
Well,
no,
I mean,
again,
to play Sasquatch advocate,
if you look at a monkey jump,
like whenever you see a monkey run up a tree,
just a monkey.
If you watch how graceful and powerful those things are,
and you consider you ever being able to do that in a million years,
you see how much more advanced in certain ways just a chimpanzee is.
Yeah.
So imagine if something had an equivalent form of advancement when it came to
being able to camouflage themselves or to hide,
you know,
maybe these things are just so good at hiding that maybe the part of evolution
that made chimpanzees able to climb a tree in five seconds,
and humans able to build
a Chrysler,
maybe that part of evolution made these beings able to hide and as super skilled
way they can cover their tracks,
they can hide in the shadows.
Why not?
It would be a great advancement for a being to be able to hide an a.
And w
no,
you're right.
You're right.
You're absolutely right.
A great advancement for a being to be able to hide though.
I'll say it.
It would be a great advancement for a being to be able to hide that way.
Yeah.
He pull up a video of bear runs up tree startles hunter.
You know that video.
This is a pretty famous video.
These guys bow hunting and while their bow hunting,
this bear just decides to make a break for it and runs up the tree.
Not that weird.
And you know bears climb trees.
I think we both know,
but did you have any fucking idea how fast they can do it?
I don't have this fair gets 20 feet up that tree in a matter of seconds like
this and all of a sudden he's up there looking eye to eye with this hunter.
Exactly.
I just want you to see,
just to put it in perspective,
let's,
let's look at it just to,
just to get a peek at it.
Watch this.
So here's the guy.
The bear comes close to him.
I don't know if this is the same one.
Did you check this one was sideways.
I was trying it
get something fast.
Let's see.
What do you mean it's sideways?
No,
that one I pulled up.
The video was sideways.
Oh really?
Pull up.
Let me see what the other video looked like.
Let me say it.
Oh,
it's sideways.
Yeah,
that's the right video.
But does it stay sideways the whole time?
I didn't even bother to look.
Go,
go a little further up.
You might figure out what the fuck he's doing wrong.
Yeah,
he does.
Now get a little bit further up and here's the bear.
Now watch this.
Watch this.
Bear move.
Okay.
Give us some volume.
The bears are already up.
Give us a volume and take it to right when the bear makes a run for it.
So the dude is up in this tree,
Stan,
he puts this food out and the way you f you hunt for bears and a lot of places,
it's not legal in California this way,
but a lot of places they let you use bait and buy bait.
The usually mean donuts.
They take a,
yeah,
yeah.
They,
they take donuts or something sweet and they put them in a barrel so that this
bear,
we'll go to that barrel and then while he's looking for his food,
that's when he killed him.
It's really trying to do shit.
That doesn't look fun at all.
It's kind of Douchey.
But if I'm watching this bear run,
look at this.
Check this out.
Look,
he makes a bolt for it and then just put it on rump.
Ah,
watch this.
Yeah.
The guy obviously fucked with his camera here.
What does that,
this is wrong.
You can show it.
What's wrong with this video?
Is this a bad video?
Why would not say in this?
Okay.
Figure it out.
Something wrong with the video.
That here's,
here's the,
the point is that this bear runs up this tree.
The way you could run straight,
like he literally runs up the tree.
It's,
it's pretty fucking insane,
right?
This is not the same video.
You can stop now,
but that,
here's the,
here's the essence of the thing.
When you look at a chimpanzee and you look at a human,
what are some of the similarities?
Well,
the similarities are both have figured out how to use tools in a rudimentary
way.
Chimpanzees use stakes to get termites out of the ground.
Humans use cars to get to their jobs.
So,
um,
why,
why is it,
why isn't it,
why isn't,
why isn't there the possibility than another primate,
instead of evolving the ability to use tools or instead of just evolving that
ability they used,
they evolved the ability to camouflage themselves.
Because in nature,
if you're a hunter,
what's a better skill than to be able to hide?
There's almost no better skill in nature.
Chameleons are almost every creature that is a predator.
There's skin has adapted to their surroundings in a way that makes them blend in
so that they could be a more powerful and efficient Predator in that way.
Why wouldn't a primate now just evolve a skin color or hair color that makes
them blend in with their environment,
but the ability to hide and a true super advanced way.
Okay.
So I'm gonna play devil's advocate please.
And this is not necessarily what I believe,
but if there was really an animal like this,
there would be something.
Now all you have is like the theater Roosevelt wrote about it in a story.
Yeah.
You know about his time,
his time in the woods,
but when a dude gets killed by a wild man,
who knows?
I mean,
who knows what really happened,
right?
And then 19 whatever the fuck it was back when teddy was running around.
The reality of life today is that if you're dealing with a very populated area,
everyone has a fucking camera on their phone.
Sure.
If everyone has a camera on their phone and no one is getting a photo of this
thing,
how many human beings are traveling through the areas where these things live
and not one person gets a picture.
And now here's the other problem.
It's iconic.
It's an archetype.
It's a thing that people go to right away is I think it's very similar to the
gray alien with the big eyes.
Yes.
I think if you are not sure what you're seeing,
your mind will create this thing.
And one of the reasons that I say this is because I read a lot about hunting
accidents and one of the things that has happened in hunting accidents is that
people who are experienced hunters who know that in order to bag a deer,
you have to capitalize on a very split moment,
a very small window in time where you got to capitalize on that in order to get
the kill right.
Well,
people have shot people accidentally and sworn up and down.
They saw a deer,
they swore up and down that they saw a dean.
Right?
And when you're talking about big foot and you're talking about bigfoot
sightings you're talking about,
first of all,
it's not a mystery.
It's not like you're talking about,
you know,
finding Rumpelstiltskin or something else.
You're talking about something that people have repeated the same stories over
and over and over again.
You're talking about something that we have a reference to in our heads,
and when you see something,
you might see just a whisper of something you don't know what the fuck you saw.
You saw something through the trees and it's dark out there.
Anyway,
busy canopy of leaves and it's never sunny out,
right.
It's always rainy and cloudy.
So what are you really seeing?
Sure.
But by the time a week goes by,
or a month goes by,
or maybe even an hour,
maybe it takes you three hours to walk to your car and you're an idiot.
And you convince yourself in those three hours that you saw his face and it
looked at you and it read your mind.
You might be so pumped up with adrenaline and fear and,
and,
and who knows?
Just longing for a life with excitement where you're not wandering through the
woods looking for fucking shadows.
Also,
half the people in the forest or high at any time,
please stop.
Nobody goes into the,
we can only base that grateful dead can.
We can only base that on our own personal experience and with you and I was 100%
so it's 100% of the people in the woods or high.
Yeah.
Cause that's all we have.
We should have got those big foot Chi Psi.
That's where we fucked up.
They were just drunk.
We should've got him high.
Yeah.
Big different results.
I,
I really mean it though.
I'm saying that people go into the woods and they get hi.
Yeah,
you're right.
If you're going to take mushrooms,
what did people always say?
Go take them and then nature takes them in the forest.
So,
and that way I would say that a lot of the observers who are experiencing these
a,
a lot of the people in the woods or maybe under the influence of Ntl of
intoxicants,
but you don't need to be right.
If I'm a kid out in the woods,
yeah,
I can hear anything,
man.
She thinks you can see things.
Dragons,
big elves.
Yeah.
Cause think of the woods.
There's no light.
Trees are shifting around.
It would be very easy to project anything.
And you know that there's a real danger.
What was that noise?
Hello?
Hello.
There was a real danger.
There's a real danger.
There's mountain lions,
there's bears,
there's wolves.
The woods contain real things that will kill you and forget about poisonous
spiders and stinks.
There's mountain lions,
bears and wolves and the woods.
So there's a real fear.
So it's a really highly charged environment.
So what you mentioned earlier,
how people prefer to have rooms on the top floor of a building or a house.
Examples like that show how embedded into our species is the trauma of having to
deal with predators in the wild.
The wildness that we evolved in.
So it makes sense that somehow inside of our neurology is imprinted the remnants
of the these predatorial forces,
the kind of combined racial memory of all the things that used to hunt us in
Itas and when we,
when,
when we go in the woods,
even today,
maybe our brains still are on alert or on guard for these things that used to
terrorize our ancestors and people who see big foot or really just seeing a
projection of this thing out into nature.
It could be that it also could be a reaction to being in the wilderness itself,
which is mostly being experienced by people who aren't native to the wilderness
when they're having these experiences.
Even if they like,
like normal campers,
the camp on every weekend,
they don't live there every day they,
they live there in short bursts and then they run back to civilization.
So in living in that environment,
there must be some thinking where you're,
you wonder what it would be like to survive out here.
One,
would it be like to survive out here without nature,
could an intelligent being do it?
Maybe he's out there.
Maybe my would brother is out there right now.
My,
my ape monkey would brother who's just as smart as me,
but chooses to not engage and remain on the outskirts of society,
eating off the land with its intelligent mind.
Hiding from people.
Yeah,
it's possible,
but it's not that likely.
It's not likely.
That's what sucks.
But why is it so sexy?
Why is it such a sexy idea?
Why is the idea of seeing big foot one of the most exciting things?
If you said to me,
Joe,
would you rather be able to fly without a plane anywhere you want it in the
world for 30 whole days or go hiking and actually meet big foot?
Wow.
I would say I'll take big foot.
I'll take big foot over 30 days of awesomeness.
What does every great dream?
You're flying,
you're flying and every great dream and then you land on a girl wants to have
sex with you.
That's what every great dream is,
okay?
This is,
I'm telling you that if you gave me 30 days of that,
I would say no.
I would rather meet big for it because I've got some questions I want to know if
it's real
well.
You know it's real.
If you meet it,
then what do you have to,
that's why I'm willing to,
big foot's going to say to you,
well,
it's going to say,
why didn't you fly?
Look at me.
I'm covered in fleas.
I live out here and shit.
Land.
You could have flown around for 30 days in assignment and talk to some hairy
failed monkey hiding from its Tinier,
smaller,
far smarter.
Brethren,
pick flying pig flying
mad.
They're like,
dude,
don't even have a phone.
Okay,
there's no fucking stores out here.
I killed elk with my face.
I've been drinking my own piss for the last thousand years.
They never have to worry about running out of water,
but they've never found a water collection device.
So that would mean that they would have to live near streams.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
there's a lot.
Look,
there's clearly a lot of problems with it here.
Well,
they're really big
too,
but then here's,
here's,
here's some on the pro side.
Here's one of the things that they always say.
Why are we found a big foot body?
Okay,
well,
here's one thing that you need to think.
Consider,
when was the last time you saw a dead mountain lion?
Okay.
There are a lot of God damn mountain lions.
I mean like a thousand of them in probably southern California alone.
She's like,
they're all over the place.
There's a lot of them.
They're not like a big foot.
It's not like a mythical creature.
It's something that we absolutely have evidence of it,
but we never see a dead one.
But they must die.
They must.
If you believe the idea that a big foot is something that has evolved,
it's ability to hide in a way that's exponentially greater than any other
animal.
Then you can also add to that the idea that they would know to bury their dead.
We bury our dead.
When was the last time you saw a dead human?
You know,
unless you're living in Syria right now,
you've probably,
it's probably,
I mean you don't see them that often.
It's a rarity.
We bury our dead.
It's not like dead bodies are always dead.
Humans are laying around and just saying maybe these apes or whatever they are,
they bury their dead,
which is why we don't see their corpses anywhere.
Right.
That's a very good point and it's a very good possibility if they really were
this intelligent thing.
And in fact,
one of the guys that we talked to,
this guy talk to,
to talk to who the fucking money,
excuse me,
one of the guys we talked,
it was a guy named William Jev Nick,
and he is a guy who had his own experience with Sasquatch when he was 14 years
old and the guy did not seem like a cook.
He was not,
he did not register at all.
I'll say that again,
did not seem like a Kook.
He did not register it all.
My crazy scale seemed like a very reasonable guy.
He's an author and he was telling his experience and he was saying that when he
was 14 years old,
he,
he saw a fucking Sasquatch.
I believe he believes it.
He believes it.
Yes.
I think there are people who believe they seen this thing.
You know,
it's for sure there's no question but that there are people who believe that
they seen a thing,
but that doesn't mean that they've actually seen the thing.
There's people in Alabama who think there's a Leprechaun and the inner cities,
it doesn't mean it's there.
This dude thinks he knows where borough ground this.
Oh,
that's why that's different.
This is where it gets weird and this is what,
this is where I had to go.
Hmm.
Because he was making sense to me.
He was a,
uh,
a reasonable man.
He obviously was educated.
He spoke very well.
We were having a,
a nice smooth conversation.
And then he tells me that he knows we're burial around is okay.
He tells me he knows where a burial ground is and he says he's known it for 20
years.
So I stop and I'm going,
well,
what are you talking about?
Like if you,
you know,
where a burial ground is,
man,
like,
hold on a second.
Why didn't you go and dig it up?
All right.
Well,
you know,
the Sasquatch,
they're not gonna like it if you do that.
Let me you something.
And this is the same thing that Tom Powell said.
Tom Powell,
who was a,
um,
a teacher in Oregon also told us that he's had Sasquatch experiences,
also told us that he wasn't a believer until something happened.
And then he saw it and then all of a sudden became a believer but also told us
he knows where Barrow Grind is.
When I said,
tell me where it is,
I go,
you tell me where it is,
I'll bring in a bunch of mercenaries and we'll dig the shit up.
Like,
let's find out what's up.
You tell me,
you know where it is.
If it's really a dangerous area,
I'll bring in a bunch of dudes with guns.
It won't be dangerous anymore.
We'll bring in people with shovels and we'll dig it up.
Come on.
If it's still there,
we'll dig it up.
Sure.
And uh,
the fact that they haven't done that is where I start going,
when are we really dealing with here?
Right?
When you're dedicating your life to this thing that you have zero evidence of,
what do you,
what are we really doing here?
And when you're telling me that you saw this thing when you were 14 years old,
I believe you.
I believe that you believe you.
It's w that's what I mean when I say I believe you.
Sure.
But I don't know.
I when people tell me stories about shit that I just did five years ago,
I go,
Oh yeah,
oh yeah,
I forgot about him.
I didn't even,
I forgot he was even there.
And then you start re re imaging,
right?
The past in your mind.
And I think that when you're dealing with something as insane as seen big foot,
especially big foot when you're 14 years old,
it gets real sketchy so that when you're repeating the story x amount of years
later,
you're basically lying.
Right.
I'm basically lying when I talk about my childhood.
Okay.
I know some very vague facts about my childhood.
Yes.
But when I tell you,
I can remember this like it was yesterday,
me and Grandpa was fishing and Grandpa was the only one that paid attention to
me and he cared.
And why I caught that fish.
He was so happy.
I don't fucking remember what Grandpa was it.
He might've been drunk.
He might've passed out.
I'm going to made it all up.
I might have,
might have danced it all in my head.
Yeah.
I don't remember what I did five days ago.
Exactly.
The whole thing's a murky blur.
I can barely remember what I had for breakfast.
Exactly.
So when someone tells you about a big foot story,
it may or may not be an accurate story.
I would say it is not an accurate story.
I don't believe in big foot.
And I think that the,
uh,
that the,
that,
uh,
having played Sasquatch advocate,
I have to say,
let me give you an example.
You know,
where a big foot burial ground is,
right?
Like,
you know that,
you know,
this thing I can tell you there,
I could take you there.
You know,
uh,
you know,
where a big foot burial ground is.
This would be one of the most monumental anthropological discoveries of,
of our generation,
of maybe,
of our time.
And you're not letting your species know about this thing.
Why,
why?
Well,
here's the thing,
Dunkin,
um,
when you've squatting,
as long as I
have,
you basically consider the squatch to be somewhat like family and a,
I don't consider these things to be creatures.
I consider these things to be my would brethren and my forest friends.
Can I ask you something?
Character Joe Rogan's playing.
Are you on a TV show right now?
Um,
occasionally I am on a TV show looking for squatch squashing.
So you're revealing to the entire planet the existence of big foot,
but you don't want to prove it with a burial ground.
Well,
I don't like the snippets of your tone,
sir.
Can,
I'll tell you right now when I'm looking for squatch,
it is 100%.
There's no bad intention involved.
I have love for the squatch.
The squatch community recognize me.
In fact,
I know their favorite food is peanut butter and Jelly.
I leave it in the gifting tree outside my house and it's often gone when I
return.
All right.
Well I gotta go.
What do you like?
Don't go and get the check.
No.
A man who lives on nothing but water and air.
No,
no water shit.
I forgot.
Oh Man.
But you,
to me it seems like it's absolutely,
if they have discovered some proof of these um,
beings existing,
I think it is unethical to not reveal it because the ethical thing to do would
be to show the burial grounds so that we can create nature preserves to protect
these precious woodland creatures from logging and all the variety of things
that
you really think that the government is going to protect the squatch.
Yes.
This was the other thing.
This guy believes,
this guy believes that the government actually is aware of the squatch.
Yes,
and the government is hiding the squatch because the government thinks that
society itself would fall apart much like an alien invasion,
much like in an alien invasion scenario,
religion would fall apart.
How do you explain the giant wood man that was not in the Bible?
How do you explain it?
10 foot tall person thing.
Who lives in the,
in the woods and can spot camera traps a mile away.
Wait a minute.
There's a scar.
Squatch I'm going to burn down the White House,
right?
All right.
Now here we go.
Proponent.
Here's proponent,
pull up.
There's a photo of gigantic [inaudible] and there's a gigantic pithy guests that
is right beside.
It's standing beside a person.
It's a,
it's a recreation.
It's a man in a recreation of this animal and this is where it gets really
weird.
Gigantic [inaudible] is an animal that they found out about in the posit carry
shop.
There's that photo and then there's another one that's kind of even more
interesting because they did it in front of a jungle.
Yeah,
that one right there.
Now look at this fucking thing.
Spread this out.
Here's what's crazy.
That was real.
That's a real animal.
They have bones.
They have teeth.
They know that this thing was bipedal base in the shape of his lower jaw.
This was an animal that existed is as a hundred thousand years ago and existed
in Asia and they didn't find out about this to the 1920s there was a guy who
went into an apothecary shop.
I should probably credit him here.
Let's see.
Gigantic.
Oh pick.
It kind of looks like an orangutan.
Yeah.
But except stands up on its fucking hind legs and it's 10 feet tall.
Other than that,
yeah,
it will be.
So then if you saw an orangutan in the zoo and right behind it was that,
you'd be like,
what the fuck is that?
It's a 10 foot tall.
Rang Tang that walks like a person.
Holy Shit.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I just liked the idea of those two actually being friends in real life,
like a superhero team.
Okay.
This is the guy's name.
The gentleman's name is [inaudible]
Ralph.
Yvonne calling's Wald,
Cohen's Wald,
Ralph Vaughan Cohen's wall.
And he was in the apothecary shop in China and there's a,
it was in a light Ching Cave in light Luzio China.
I might've said that wrong.
Anyway,
he found these teeth as well as several job bones and this apothecary shop.
And he apparently he was a,
um,
he was,
uh,
I believe he's an anthropologist.
And he went and he found these bones and I think he recognized right away that
these were primate.
Right.
And that they were way too big to be human and way too big to be gorilla.
He was like,
what the fuck is this?
Right.
The people in the Chinese apothecary shop just thought they had some random
bones.
Sure.
And they actually were calling them dragging bones.
Um,
and uh,
they trace these teeth back to their source and it resulted in recovery,
have more teeth and a rather complete large mandible.
Now by 1958,
it says here on Wikipedia that three mandibles and 1300 teeth had been
discovered.
So they know that this is a,
for sure real animal and the most recent fossils are a hundred thousand years
ago.
That's when you look at that thing and you hear a big foot story.
That's fuck,
that's fucking big foot.
I mean that thing next to that guy is big foot.
Right.
But again,
they didn't find a skull.
They found teeth in a job bone and they made Chubak out of it.
They didn't find a skull.
It's true shape
of the lower jaw.
They couldn't determine that this was a bipedal animal.
Okay.
Cause it's not determined it's hair color.
No,
that's,
that's totally made up.
That's also with Neanderthal,
you know,
within thall notice I said all this time when,
when you,
um,
look at neanderthal imagery,
that's all made up.
In fact,
there is a,
a guy who thought of Neanderthal is a Predator and he had this whole paper that
he wrote and,
and,
and he even had a video made of proposing that neanderthal had black skin,
like a gorilla.
And that neanderthal where these super muscular predators that hunted humans,
and that's why we drove them to extinction.
And he actually bases this on the shape of their jaw.
She's like,
we impose human characteristics to neanderthals,
but if you look at it in the end,
are tall skull next to a homosapien skull,
they're very different.
The shape of the eyes different.
Now,
if we know the chimpanzees exist and we know the grills exist and we know that
their facial structure is actually more similar to a neanderthal than ours are.
Yeah,
why wouldn't we assume that they had skin coloring and,
and,
and skin texture that was very guerrilla like right.
And so this guy made this video,
see if you could pull that up neander tall as a,
as a Predator
of humans,
as a Predator of humans,
free tour of humans.
I'll tell you what I find.
It's called them and us.
Okay.
So look up them,
them and us how the neanderthals were a oppressed.
But this guy had um,
images that he created and he,
he wrote a book detailing this theory and I'm,
his theory was that we had excepted a vision of what Niana tall looked on,
looked at,
looked like based entirely on what we look like,
right.
And he saying,
well,
there's no evidence of that and you might as well,
you might as well look at it as being far closer to a gorilla.
And he gives a bunch of reasons that have to do with the size of the bones.
Sure.
They had much different bone structure than us.
They were like 200 plus pounds and they were like five feet tall.
They were totally weird looking.
There were not like a person.
Yes,
it's just in the reconstruction that you just showed me.
If you're saying this came from teeth and a jawbone and you're saying this was
done by the professor,
Loreal guy in the picture with the hairy Orangutang like thing,
I want to know where did you get the hair color from?
Why is the hair color that long?
This being it'll know.
Listen.
You know what I mean?
You're right about that for sure.
Because I think anybody could take a few teeth in a Java on and stick that into
a Sasquatch replica and say,
look,
it's proof mom.
Yeah,
sort of.
I mean,
I guess you could,
but what we do know,
I mean that's just speculation,
but we do know this is,
this is a real animal.
So whatever this was,
whether it looked like that.
Yeah.
Or it didn't look like that.
We know it was huge.
Well,
this is absolutely gigantic,
far bigger than any primate that's ever lived since then or before then.
As far as we know,
if you look in the book of Genesis,
there's reference to these beings called the nephilim.
Then nephilim were these giants.
They said they were giants during this time.
And,
um,
you know,
who knows whether that's real or not.
But I think all mythologies have referenced to these giant human things that
used to wander the earth.
Well,
we know,
think about human giants that we know about.
Okay?
Think about guys like Shaquille O'Neal or Hong Man,
Troy or real giants,
right?
They have a lot of physical problems.
And then think about what it takes to create a fossil.
It's incredibly difficult to create a fossil.
The only way you create a fossils,
if you get caught in a landslide or a volcano or something happens where it
preserves your body,
you can get in mud.
But most of us are not going to be fossils.
Most of us are just going to rot.
We're going to go into the ground and then worms are going to eat us,
and then we're going to cease to exist.
So we're going to be transmuted into the next age of the afternoon.
I haven't praise,
praise,
praise Shiva.
But what we,
what we do know is that there's been people our size and then there's been these
little tiny hobbit people.
Yes.
I think it would be ridiculous to think that it's not possible.
They could have been giant piece.
Sure.
There was giant lizards,
giant birds.
There's been giant elephants.
Giant Tiger's.
If you go down to the labrea tar pits,
just check out the sculptures of the dire wolves out there.
Those things used to wander around Los Angeles.
How big were they?
Huge.
Like horse size wolf.
What?
Direwolves Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Now they're not going to be horse size.
I'm gonna say probably huge.
Well,
did you?
Yeah.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
did you ever Dire Wolf Los Angeles?
She's going to bring up a crappy band.
Remains of nearly 2000 dire wolf's were Exuma.
They lived 9,000 years ago.
Okay.
How big were they or not?
It doesn't say
there were huge.
All I believe you bro.
Look at,
I mean,
look at,
look at a saber tooth tigers for God's sake.
Look at those things.
Those things used to wander around La.
Well,
not only that,
that was only like 10,000 years ago.
Yeah.
So the idea that there were giant humans are giant primates is not,
to me a particularly shocking notion.
I believe that it's just hard for me to imagine that one of them has managed to
somehow exist in the present day.
It's also disturbed
bang.
And this is one of the things that we resist.
We resist danger that we're not aware of.
When you're resistant,
like call,
come on.
I was talking to someone about a,
um,
this is a community that's experiencing,
they,
uh,
they live near a factory and they're experiencing like all these issues.
And I was talking to someone who,
uh,
it was saying like,
hey man,
like this,
this community might be poisoned because of his factory.
And then I talked to another guy,
I was like,
oh listen,
that's nonsense.
Let me tell you something that if that was true and he starts rattling off some
reasons why he doesn't believe it's true.
And then I asked him if he had looked into it and he hadn't.
And then I realized,
okay,
we're dealing with like reactions that humans have when we want to categorize
dangers and we want to put them in it clearly definable categories and we have
to wonder whether we want to worry about them.
And some things you worry about never take place.
And if that's happens,
then you're a little worry wart and you're a pussy and then you're ruining
society,
right?
Because you're a big wimp and people don't want to be a big wimp.
So when people don't want to be a big Wimp,
they dismiss things that may or may not be real and may or may not be a danger.
And they do it as a defense mechanism.
And so it's not entirely objective the reaction to any,
any thing.
Well,
when you bring up big foot people immediately,
ah,
shy,
you're gonna love for big foot guide and look for the,
Oh,
what else are you going to look for?
Leprechauns well,
let me know when you find a Pegasus
out there,
fella,
and take a ride around the world in the flying in horse,
it's probably real.
I mean the Greeks made a statue of it.
Why would they,
why,
right?
Why would they lie?
And what he's doing by berating you and by dismissing this topic is not just
dismissing something that is preposterous and is ludicrous and stupid,
but he's also making himself feel better because he's scared because he's a
scared little bitch.
Worried about that guy started big foot and his giant Rasputin Dwarfing Dick,
big foot must have a dick like a giraffe.
It was probably like a giraffe neck tied to his cock.
It's just is gigantic and it's probably black,
like coal.
I'm scared of so many things.
I'm scared of taking my shirt off at a swimming pool,
but I am not scared of bigfoot.
And my reason for not believing in bigfoot is not because I'm afraid that my
belief in bigfoot,
some big foot's gonna come trouncing into my house in Silverlake.
I'm,
I don't believe in,
first of all,
you fucked up and telling people where you live.
Second of all,
hunt me down.
And second of all,
you say all this shit because you haven't seen Bobcat Goldthwait it's movie
Willow Creek.
I like to watch bobcat calls,
wigs,
big fuck movie,
which is sensational.
It's amazing.
You'll shit your pants,
you're gonna be afraid to get out of the car and take a leak if it's dark out
and you're near a patch of woods.
Look,
I don't know if big foot's real and I know you don't know if big foot's right,
but I know that we both think it's an interesting subject.
Why is that?
Well,
because it's a beautiful idea.
It's this idea of a being that is somehow managed to evolve to a place past the
intelligence of chimpanzees and gorillas and yet simultaneously has reached this
harmony with nature and is living out there and some kind of beautiful
primordial pagan state.
There's something really wonderful about that idea.
It's like avatar depression.
Yes.
It's like a version of Avatar depression.
Like when people went to see that movie Avatar,
when you see those noble people who would never lie,
and although they may exhibit a little bit of jealousy and they take that fake
Navi into their arms because they're beautiful people and they get their
internet from a tree and it comes down from this,
this have some sort of a wifi thing where it's like the float and whatever,
they can hide their tails.
Yeah,
exactly.
But there's something about that that's wonderful.
And one of the things that you and I experienced is we went and we,
we went to mount Rainier with the lovely and talented cast and crew and we,
we went up there and we wandered through those woods and we went to a bunch of
different areas where people have claimed to have seen Sasquatch before.
And the thing that's struck me,
besides the fact that it was unbelievably beautiful up there,
I have never been to the woods of the Pacific northwest in my adult life.
I actually talked to my dad about it and he said we went camping up there when
we were was when I was much,
much younger.
I think I won like seven and I don't remember it because apparently it was like
rainy and miserable and we hated it and we got out of there like it wouldn't be
like the funnest place to go camping,
but it literally is an,
I hate the word,
literally.
Sorry.
Used it really is like you're stepping into another dementia.
Yes.
It's beautiful and it's so rich with plant life.
Yeah,
it's the plant life.
This is how you consider it.
Let's pretend that the,
the salt lake is a blank slate.
Okay.
Salt Lake in Utah was that flat?
The flat plains or there's the salt flats where they race cars,
they take cars and the going a thousand miles an hour because there's nothing
out there,
but it's flat salt.
Right.
If that's a flat plane and that's a zero life environment.
The,
the rain forests of the Pacific northwest is a 100% life environment.
Yes.
Every inch is taken up by plant life.
There's elk running across.
We stepped an elk shit every other step everywhere.
It was everywhere.
We were driving down the road.
Elk would just walk right in front of us.
These giant wild cows,
which are more related to cows in the yard to a deer.
Actually,
she huge,
enormous,
four or 500 pound animals just walking across the street.
It's a wild place to sit.
You have an accurate account on that.
Like what are you going up there and measuring shit.
Who's going up there?
You know?
Even though it's right next to Seattle,
even though it's 50 plus miles outside of Seattle,
no one's going into those words.
No one.
And when you're there and you take that in,
that's when you really start considering it.
You really started going with eight maybe.
Sure.
You know when I went out there,
I didn't realize how dense it was out there.
I,
I had never considered that.
And when you see how dense it is and how thick it is out there,
then you do start entertaining the idea that there's the possibility that some
extremely endangered being could be hiding out in these depths because people
aren't going to go into that.
What purpose do people have for going into that stuff?
The,
I imagine that there's naturalists and maybe hardcore hikers who are crossing
maybe point 10th of a percent of that terrain,
if that,
yeah,
so in that way you could see how there could be a being existing out there that
maybe hadn't been discovered yet
and when we sent the drones up into the sky to like overlook the area and when
you put the goggles on and you could see through the drones and you're flying
over the,
it's majestic.
Yeah.
I mean it is majestic.
It is unlike any place that I have ever been to in my life.
I was humbled by the life.
Yeah.
Humbled by the plant life.
There's something about the amount of trees that you see up there in the density
of it.
All that is just like,
it puts you right in your place.
It just goes sit down and look at this and you,
you,
it's almost like psychedelic,
like you walk into those forests,
it's almost the whole world changes and when you're in there,
you might as well be in another dementia.
Sure.
It's so not the human world and you walk in and every hour or so you'll find
some shit on the ground that a person left behind,
but you're on.
Once you're cutting one path,
how much are you dealing with around you that you never see?
If you lived up there in the Pacific northwest for the rest of your natural life
and just every day you just crossed a,
a certain area off your list and just walked up and down and up and down and you
made a grid,
you're,
you're going to die before you ever see true.
Even a tiny fraction of the woods that are around you.
And even with all the logging going on up there,
it's not happening in every single part of that area.
So
not only that,
I mean you'd want to make the argument for us and intelligent animal being able
to avoid you.
How much easier is it to know you're there then when you're chopping fucking
trees down with a saw that go,
right,
I'm listening for elk SnapID twigs.
Okay.
And I hear a fucking saw and I smelled that stinky fuel burning.
Yeah.
Uh,
if,
uh,
if a gorilla for whatever reason,
got pushed out of a van in the middle of Brooklyn,
it would stick out in the most profound way.
It would within four seconds around the entire world will be videos of a gorilla
in Brooklyn.
And the same way a human wandering through the Pacific northwest with our stinky
perfumes and deodorants on smelling of the cheese burger you just ate before.
You're weird,
impotent little hike,
you know,
two miles into the wilderness,
that would be so easy to avoid.
Creatures can already avoid us.
Anyway.
Cotton root beer farts.
Yeah,
we're in doctor Scholls.
Bud Light in your backpack.
Old Spice on your stupid armpits.
Yeah.
This think of your tumor is coming out of your mouth.
They smell that stupid fluoride toothpaste you wash your face with.
So it'd be so we would,
we stick out like a sore thumb in that,
in that terrain,
even though our ancestors,
that's what we used to live in.
We were born into that.
It used to be where we were born into that wilderness.
And there's something that happens when you go out there under that wildness
where some mild little shift happens to you.
You know,
there is something that happens in another part of your mind begins to activate
when you're out there.
And I think that part of your mind that activates is the part of the mind that
Sasquatch hunters use when they hallucinate.
They're imaginary.
They see,
well,
unfortunately that might be actually what's happening.
That's what's,
what's,
um,
that's what's the most messy part of this situation is that you can't pick a
horse.
You don't want to be the guy that says no Sasquatch.
You guys are silly because that guy's a dick.
Sure.
Okay.
And you don't want to be the guy that goes
all Sasquatch,
bigfoot research centers of America and gets it tattooed on your ass either
because that guy's a dick as well.
I don't want to be a guy squatting.
What does squatch what is,
what'd you say?
Squatch was again when we were out there.
Watch is then a name for the uh,
dried semen that accrues and the hair and the beard hair truckers.
You've been hanging out at truck stop glory holes called squad.
Oh,
I shit.
And then you got some squats and your beer brother.
He's the reason why the hardcore homos at truck stops only on mustaches.
Right?
Because we all know the hardcore gay dudes.
There's like three types of people that have mustaches.
Mexicans,
John Stossel and hardcore gay dude inhaler.
The kind of hardcore gay dudes that were like leather biker hats and like cutoff
Jean shorts with Timberland's.
Yeah.
Hardcore,
hardcore,
thick pasty.
They're trying to avoid squash and they don't want to deal with Washington squat
beard.
It's annoying clumps up and it smells like dried bleach,
burnt rubber.
When you wash it out.
Greg Fitzsimmons goes on stage in San Francisco where we're doing San Francisco
together.
He goes on stage and he goes,
you know what I love about San Francisco?
He's still have real faggots.
I think it was real guys with like Jean leather vest on but and cutoff Jean
shorts and that's hilarious.
Like the Blue Oyster bar and police academy,
there was a lot of gay people in the crowd too.
And they,
they loved it.
They were cheering,
you know,
and that,
that kind of stuff drives me crazy because on paper or if you put that on the
Internet,
people can get mad at him.
He could.
But,
but Greg Fitzsimmons is like one of the least homophobic guys you will ever meet
in your life.
Like he has a great story about wanting to find out whether or not he was in the
gay sex when he was young.
So he like got drunk and got up his courage and then like found a guy and his
gay area that he knew and went to the woods with them and then fucking panicked
and ran away.
He's like,
I know,
but like he's not even remotely homophobic.
Like he's not afraid of telling that story.
He's not homophobic at all.
So when he goes up there and says,
I love San Francisco is still has a lot of faggots.
Yeah.
And like they,
they like were clapping.
I saw a gay couple that were like going there,
cause he was saying it was,
it was in,
within coming from anger or fear.
It's coming from an accurate assessment of San Francisco.
And that's fine.
It's not a,
it's not a black or white issue.
Not to Hertz.
There's,
there's,
uh,
there's a lot of shit going on when you say that word because a lot of shit,
you can say it in a beautiful way.
And the way he was saying it was describing a wild looseness and an acceptance
of homosexuality in San Francisco that allows men to be really flamboyant.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
Sure.
That's a good thing.
So what he was saying was a good thing,
but that's what's pissing me off about this current state of like criticizing
standup comedy is if it's a statement,
these are not statements.
We're saying we're saying wacky shit,
we're just talking.
What makes the thing offensive is the energy behind it.
When you hear a fundamentalist right wing Christian,
say homosexual,
it's the same way as when you hear a Nazi,
say the word Jew,
it comes out in this like sizzling.
It's like,
it's the sound of like,
you know,
and the alien when they kill the alien and that acid drips through the metal,
it's that same,
just vile is dripping hate homeless.
It's like all the hate inside.
That person is coming through the window of the word homosexual and that's
offensive.
But when Greg Fitzsimmons says Faggot,
that's like somebody throwing glitter in front of a disco ball.
There's nothing dangerous or angry or pissed off as sweet.
There's nothing bad about it.
And isn't it funny that when,
this is something that took a while for humans to figure out,
but now there is a knee jerk reaction that when someone rallies against
homosexuals is angry about homosexuals as fighting off homosexuals.
They're most likely k 100% k most likely gay.
Just so when did people figure that out?
Was it 1980 I don't know how it even happened.
I think that's way more recent that people want to admit.
I think the idea like was really crystallized with Ted Haggard.
Sure.
When that guy got busted in his gay prostitute friend who likes to do math with,
went on CNN and was like,
that guy's crazy.
Yeah,
I might be a gay prostitute.
That doesn't mess with my clients,
but this guy's fucked up mind guys,
this guy's out there fucking making mistakes.
The weight,
the weight Christians come out of the closet is they say they hate gay people.
That's how you know you're gay.
If you ever ever hear a Christian talk about how bad it is to be a homosexual,
it's 100% you're like,
you poor bastard.
Just do it.
True,
true.
Yeah.
And who cares?
It's like the what?
What's good about being gay is you get to find out who's an idiot around you.
If you came out and you were gay and some people got upset at you,
great.
You found the idiots in your neighborhood.
Yeah.
Unfortunately for a lot of people,
if their fucking parents,
I mean when you,
when you look at when they post letters on reddit where like people come out of
the closet and their parents write letters saying you have to leave the house
and will never talk to you again.
It's like,
oh,
they got off light man.
If they had good friends,
they got off light.
I swear to God.
If my parents would like that and I was gay,
I swear to got to be happy.
Now tonight,
right?
2013 at 45 you mean you escape from using with mass holes in a certain point in
your life,
you have to realize that your family is not just what you were born with,
Shit.
It's also what you accept,
what you bring into your world and what you create when you,
yeah.
When you're 14 right?
Of course and
your worst.
Think about just just think of the reverse.
I mean it's like if when I was 15 and I knew that,
I told my parents that I loved going down on this veiny albino and,
and
I would like to thank that.
If you are my son,
I could work through that with you.
I would like to tell you that listen,
there's no perfection to this life.
And there's the beautiful thing about life is it everybody likes something
different.
Okay.
And then everybody is different.
Some people have blue eyes,
some people love to suck.
Cock.
No,
I'm not saying sucking cock.
I'm thinking,
imagine if you as a child knew that talking about you,
telling your parents that you like licking pussy would get you thrown out of
your house.
Imagine the horror of that.
Like your entire sex drive.
Sure.
In a teenager you,
your sex drive is like you have sclerosis explosive.
And to know that,
revealing that that Makin revealing that mechanism to your parents could
actually get you banished from,
could make you homeless.
It's terrifying when you're 14 that's fun.
It's terrifying.
But you know what the real problem is?
Human beings have isolated themselves into these much,
much more small and more segregated communities.
And we call them families,
right?
And we know we're not in a community anymore that has a hundred people in it.
We're all going hunting together and,
and,
and sharing festivities were on the fire.
Now we're in these communities where we have tribes of like a very small group
at four or five people.
That's right.
You know,
my tribe is a,
I have three daughters in May.
That's my tribe,
you know,
and I have friends who I allow into my camp occasionally and we break bread and
then they go back to their tents and that's it.
Yeah.
And that's the reality of modern man.
The old days,
people,
tribes up together and they got,
you know,
50,
60 people and they got together and they all knew everybody and they,
they,
they existed in these communities where they all shared hunting duties and
cleaning duties and parental duties.
And that was how people lived a long time ago.
What were we really fucked up as we removed accountability,
when we stopped being communal,
we stopped being communal in our child rearing.
We stopped being communal in our,
our our relationships.
Sure.
And that's where like bitch behavior comes from to when you got a guy who like
starts texting your wife or your girlfriend or you know a girl you're dating and
says like stupid shit about you.
Like that's supposed to all be done.
Like out in the open.
Yeah.
When a guy starts sneaking around on Facebook and saying mean shit about you to
somewhere,
what is he doing?
He's revealing his wheat genetics.
He's a loser.
The guy's a bitch and the girl will never respect him.
What he's doing,
he,
she's,
she knows what he's doing.
She knows he's being like,
we can see creepy and Shitty,
but they think we'll just turn to tell you that goes,
doesn't appreciate you.
I know he does where he is with you.
I see that you're hurting on the inside and then just want to look totally
platonic.
I am your friend.
I mean,
I don't,
you're very beautiful and I would be honored if you ever be with me,
but I know you're known to be so friends.
This guy's an asshole.
Why does that Guy Exist?
Because you can't go hunting with them.
And woopsie got hit by our streets beer book now that he's supposed to take that
guy with you on,
on the,
the manly duties and throw him in a lake,
some white sand pits made for that type of human.
That type of behavior is not supposed to be fostered to the point where he's,
uh,
a member of society,
a trusted member of society.
But oftentimes in communities,
people deal with deceptive,
like traders,
traders of their friendship traders of there because we've separated,
we've removed accountability.
You can shut your door and lock it and just send the country email and everybody
has removed themselves from this process of,
of community.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
it's amazing how are,
how,
how bad that is for our continued evolution.
The fact that people like that,
um,
have any kind of impact at all is pretty horrific.
And that's where Avatar depression comes in
cause it shit doesn't exist in Avatar and it doesn't exist in the squash
community either.
Right.
I don't think there's any bitch squashes.
I think squash is in my mind.
Okay.
Whether or not the real in my world squashes are noble,
they're very smart.
They run after elk and they check them.
They probably choke them.
They'd probably get a good strong rear naked.
Yeah,
I'd probably just break their necks.
Uh,
uh,
Alex probably made out of Styrofoam compared to a squat
when we went squashing one of those guys said,
I liked what you said that because it is true.
When we went squatting,
when we thought we went through,
a few people can say that we went squashing and I remember one of the,
I clearly remember one of our fellows squashers our teachers squatters.
They said that the way the Sasquatch hunts is it breaks the leg of the elk and
then after snapping it's leg,
that's when it kills it.
I don't know why it doesn't kill it all at once,
but it grabs,
it breaks its leg and then lets it kind of pull itself through the wilderness
and then eats it.
That's the way the noble Sasquatch hunts.
It also can turn into a bird and it also can sound like a leaf blower.
I can also tell you that that gentleman,
the same gentleman that told you that story also told me that one time he was in
front of a blackberry Bush and he heard a frog.
It was like,
read it,
and he said,
now why would a frog behind in a blackberry Bush?
And he goes,
you know what I thought about?
I was like,
that's probably a big foot.
Yeah,
sure.
So just say no.
Same Guy.
I came,
God,
there's some critical thinking right there that it should be in the CIA.
I see.
Hear a frog.
It's near a blackberry.
Bush must be an undiscovered primate of enormous proportions.
Fucking shit.
It could be.
Maybe it's a crazy frog.
Maybe it's a frog.
That eight,
a psychedelic mushroom doesn't know what the fuck is going on.
He's hiding in bushes.
He can't even eat berries.
He's lying on his back.
He's,
he's,
he's flying on a rainbow glitter all the way to Jupiter that he's a frog and
he's understanding space travel for the first time and he knows that he's got a
couple minutes to go before the silicide and leaves the system and then it
becomes a frog again.
Just what's around flies.
Can I make one point real quick about this?
I think squashing is the hiking what renaissance fairs are to parks.
It's,
it's I,
how do I say that better?
No,
no,
no.
I just watch watching in history to history.
I think squashing is to hiking what renaissance fairs are to history.
I think it's a way to turn hiking into this exciting play time,
play time.
That's what it is.
I think that's what it is as that you totally right.
I think you're totally right.
And I met with a guy named Scott Nelson and he's a crypto linguist.
In fact,
he worked for the US Navy for almost 20 years to ciphering languages and he
played me some authentic,
I'm doing air quotes.
Okay.
Authentic,
big foot language and I want to play it for you because it's,
it's pretty fascinating stuff.
He played me,
this is what's disturbing though.
He played me two very different recordings.
One of them sounded like total dog shit and I listened to it.
I was like,
does not a big foot.
That's a guy and he goes,
no person could make that sound.
I was like,
oh good.
We'll go.
We'll go there.
I made the sound like I made the same sound.
It really did sound but he played me another one that was called,
they call it Samurai chatter.
Okay.
That is really weird.
Cool and I would love it if once this show comes on the air,
I know a lot of you are going to be like,
this is fucking bullshit.
I can explain.
I am a language expert and had some very educated points about this,
this language that he had heard online.
Now he went into this a complete skeptic.
He had no idea that there was like a big foot community out there and no idea
that people who are scientists took it seriously,
but his son was doing a project and it was playing him this big foot stuff and
him being in crypto linguistics like,
well,
wait a minute,
what is that?
Hmm.
And so he plays it and listens to it over and over again and immediately
recognizes that this is a language and that's where it gets weird because you're
talking about a guy who is a,
a real bonafide expert in human language.
He's an expert in phonemes and different,
different aspects of,
of,
of human language and how to distinguish them.
So he's what's called a crypto linguists was mean.
She would take a language that's an unknown language and decipher it.
Okay.
So he listens to this and um,
and he decides this is a real thing.
Like,
oh my God.
So he thinks that big foot's real.
I'm going to play you what he played for me.
Cool.
Chuck this
who several years had a cabin way up in the remotest parts of the Sierras,
northern California.
And he was there one time with a friend and uh,
every evening they used to have some absolutely bizarre noises.
Um,
cool.
So then they couldn't figure out what the hell it was and I'm so they took the
tape recorder one time and this is what the record is.
Listen to this shit.
It is very bizarre indeed.
We decided to record the sounds fucking weird that I was in a cabinet and I
heard that,
oh Jesus,
my hair would Tommy.
Why Low Creek Bobcat Goldthwait sticks.
People look into it.
They are very encouraged.
What?
This is more of this or is it more sounds.
These sounds,
scroll a little further ahead and give me some more of this,
right.
Listen to this.
So this is what he determined.
He listened to this and he listened to the sounds and it was his expert opinion
that these are not sounds that are created by a human bot.
Yeah.
The,
this,
the tone that this speed of the pitch though,
the way that the language is being like exhibited,
he believed that this is a language but that it's not being used by a human
being.
It sounds chimp,
like it does sound like,
it definitely sounds like a gorilla mixed in with,
I see why they call it Samurai it sounds like.
Yeah,
Asian.
Somehow there's something underneath it.
I would love to slow it down and hear what it is.
Well he did.
He did.
He slowed it down.
And it's interesting that you say that.
He slowed it down from me and he broke down very specific aspects of it that he
recognized as language.
And again,
you know,
we're talking about a guy who was a crypto linguist expert,
a language expert for the navy,
so he knows what he's talking about and it is very,
very compelling.
I don't know where that came from though.
Right?
I mean they say that it was a bunch of people in the Sierra Nevada's and they
recorded this.
All we're hearing is some really weird noises that a language experts say sounds
like some sort of an animal.
Oh
no,
but you're not even close.
Oh,
there's,
there's some quality to it that just doesn't seem human.
I might be wrong because,
look,
we've,
we've all seen people that are impressionists that do things.
Do you go,
how are you doing that?
Right.
You know,
we've all seen that.
Yeah.
So it,
it,
it might be,
you know,
I can make a dog when your dog.
Yes.
Jesus,
that's a dog.
But it's not a doubt this don't do that.
We ever do that to your kids when they're sleeping?
No.
How rude.
One time though,
when we were on fear factor,
there was this,
uh,
this group of people and they were blindfolded and we led them into this,
this room,
or they didn't know what the stunt was,
so they couldn't see it because it was a big wheel.
And you know,
they would have saw it immediately and said,
what's the wheel for?
So they,
him in blindfolded.
So as they bring it in,
blindfold them and go,
they would shit their pants dirty fucks.
So I don't know what a person can and can't make with the noise,
cause I have to make some weird noises with my boss and the guy from police
academy.
I perfect Winslow.
Perfect.
Colin's low could easily do something like that.
Yeah.
So you can't just say because you're hearing some strange,
guttural orc like language that it's definitely a big foot.
That's something that could easily be fake Dunkin.
There's only one way to solve this problem.
Okay,
well you go to the woods with me and go and
no,
come on
now.
So why would I deny it's a dream come true.
I love to go.
Squatch all right,
let's go.
Squatch let's do it.
Let's do this.